tonight
120 retired generals have slammed
president biden
as being mentally unfit as an ongoing
i screwed it up i was gonna try and go
for it i couldn't do it you did good
though
i was trying cause what did i do did i
do something wrong no no i just
got nervous for a second i was gonna try
and do this bit it didn't work i just
totally flubbed it
do it again welcome on tonight's news
uh so there's a gas shortage and uh food
food shortages in certain areas and
hyperinflation
and uh elon musk says we're not going to
be here's what i love bitcoin drops
because elon musk says we're not going
to sell it
i'm like this is the craziest thing ever
bitcoin's like we're no longer accepting
bitcoin because it's environmentally
unfriendly that means we will never sell
our bitcoin position
and people are like quick sell your
bitcoin what why
he just said he's gonna hold and not and
and restrict
supply anyway oh man 120 retired
generals
come out and they're like biden's brain
is broken the
the election system is they're like
they're questioning the integrity of the
election
no integrity no integrity they're saying
you know democrats are saying it's
racist to have ids when like all these
other countries are doing it oh yeah
britain
yeah yeah yeah we got we got a lot to
talk about man i'll tell you one thing
too is really crazy we'll get to this
later
there are these viral videos of people
putting magnets where they got their
vaccines
and it's some of like the dumbest stuff
i've ever seen but what's really
annoying is how bad the media is at
debunking these things
so anyway long story short there's a
viral trend where people take magnets
and put it on their arms and then claim
there's a microchip it's not real
but i suppose it's
i don't know how you debunk it because
these media outlets are just like
scientists
say it can't be real it's like okay well
that's not you're not what are you doing
that's
we we sliced open their arm and found no
evidence in metal yeah they didn't do
anything that's the way but we'll talk
about it we'll talk about it and i think
it's
i think it's just like people have found
a way to get views yeah it's that's like
the easiest way to do it those people
people in search of views clout chasers
exactly let me just say
the people the people who are doing this
i don't think realize that like
microchips
for the most part are like not magnetic
unless it's like a cobalt nickel
microchip i guess pre-show tim was
giving us quite a lesson
what metals are so dumb like what do
they do like a chunk of iron in your arm
no steel all right all right there are
some
but it just it's these it's so silly
anyway we get to debunk this stuff
so uh here's the way to debunk them you
just send all those people through an
mri
yeah let's see what happens then yep
yeah yeah i i think people are just like
on tick tock and they're like look
they put sticky the same people
complaining about the chip in their arm
or these people too
walking out the phone attached to their
bodies at all times so
we'll talk about the news of course
jack's here jack is here i'm here it's
every other wednesday i'm jack murphy
i'm here with my great friend
ian uh by the way if you have some time
please do check out my youtube channel
hit subscribe reminder
share it all those things follow me on
twitter jacqueline what youtube channel
you didn't mention what the name of it
was it's
jack murphy live jack if you're live all
over the internet jack murphy
just type it right into google and then
go down the list and hit follow on all
of them
what about you ian well my name is ian
crossland hello thank you jack
and you can follow me at encryption.net
if you'd like to see my stuff that's ian
crossland.net i already follow you i'm
so glad
yeah actually actually i really like you
yeah as a person
the flirting has begun early tonight
stopping this lydia's question yeah yeah
uh ian didn't throw it to me i was
waiting for that oh well i'm here in the
corner pushing buttons and laughing at
these guys it's great
before we get started head over to
timcast.com
and click this big blue members only but
in the top right you can become a member
with stripe or paypal and uh my friends
have you heard
they gave stephen crowder two strikes i
think it was today i think today
yesterday but probably today
two strikes on on on his main channel he
now has two strikes
which means one more strike and they
permanently ban him and on his crowder
bits channel
they gave him one hard strike which
means because his main channel has two
strikes he can't post anywhere on
youtube for two weeks
the purge is real they don't want
anti-establishment conversations
which very often overlap with a lot of
conservative conversations so
in the event that crowder goes down you
know that's there's a bunch of people
who are next we're probably on that list
somewhere
go to timcast.com become a member to
help make sure that if that happens
we can keep working and you also get
access to amazing members-only content
in the members area right up top you can
see
we have a bunch of really amazing videos
we talked yesterday about
people wanting us to eat cicadas i
talked about chickens with daniel
and ian claimed that shroom's made his
friend's dog sentiment you got to see
you oh i wish you could have been there
she got into like an eighth of mushrooms
and
and the dog just became like i'm alive
personality all right all right all
right
if you want to see that go to
timcast.com become a member you can
watch the video
and don't forget to like share and
subscribe to this channel share this
video take the url
seriously there someone posted this
video in their or this photo and they're
like this is what happens when people
share
and it was a major spike in like the
youtube like uh a viewer count or
whatever like you can see the bar graph
take the link put it on twitter facebook
whatever uh you know help leverage that
i suppose
and uh if you're sitting on itunes
spotify or whatever give us five stars
leave us a good comment
let's get into the serious news
so i mentioned this story a moment ago
for those that aren't familiar
more than 120 retired generals and
admirals sign open letter questioning
biden's mental health and backing
election fraud claims
i mentioned this and the first thing
that uh jack said
what did you say are we back to trusting
uh you know retired officials of all
kinds experts i mean didn't we just
spend the last four years reading
letters from
all kinds of lists of people saying a
hundred of these guys said that donald
trump is insane
remember these guys hundred of these
guys those guys are those guys and now
we got 120 of these
m f and guys but i believe these guys
that's right because they think the way
i think that's right
yes correct you know uh i saw the 350
whatever
um former military uh officers saying
trump was unwell
and i was deeply offended and it was
clearly fake news
clearly then i opened up this story from
the daily mail and these 100
retired generals clearly are the ones
who are of sound mind they were the
smart ones
obviously nothing but the best i got to
be honest though i
i do think these guys are right like
biden is not all there
he's definitely not so i mean you know
obviously we have our bias i suppose
but uh here's the story for the daily
mail they say
the letter echoes former president
trump's claims of widespread election
fraud which have been
born uh which have not been brought out
in the courts and
uh come on a day when liz cheney ripped
trump for his claim the election was
stolen now i'll mention this too
what may be the stupidest most boring
story
i have ever seen in any news cycle liz
cheney getting stripped of some
republican committee woman position who
is she jane's daughter i'm joking
no no but what what was her position
what was her position
i have no idea and who cares i have no
character i'm like i'm sitting here
reading the news and it's like
two weeks ago there was reports out of
ohio nebraska
uh uh and and arkansas food shortages a
bunch of different restaurants are like
we can't get food why
you see these stories about how people
are walking off the job
like we don't want to work at wendy's or
whatever that's happening at processing
plants it's happening at factories it's
happening at steel mills happening
everywhere people get paid not to work
i'm seeing that story we'll get into
more of that later i'm seeing the story
i'm like wow this is scary
and then i look on on twitter and it's
like liz cheney liz cheney i'm like who
cares about liz cheney
is there is there is there a 45 year old
dad you know looking at his two
daughters in the corner thinking to
himself like oh man
if liz cheney doesn't get removed i
don't know my future's gonna be like or
my daughter's
no he's like do i have food tomorrow is
there gasoline the democrats just shut
down
are demanding another pipeline be shut
down in michigan because they're worried
at a leak in the in the lake
which hasn't happened before apparently
and it's weird timing to shut down
a pipeline when we have this other thing
going on anyway i digress that'd be
three in one year for them
yeah exactly wow so let's see what these
uh these are these are generally
and that was the thing that was just the
day after that was like basically the
head i think of all the department of
energy maybe was our department of
transportation one of them the lady was
saying
well pipelines are definitely the best
way to that's right
yep talk about weird it's it's
i got to say it when i saw that story
about democrats shutting down the
pipeline in north michigan
it goes into ontario i guess for for uh
processing refining but still that
helps supply the region and i'm just
like are they
trying to destroy everything are they
are they actually like mustache twirling
villains who want to burn the system
down because it's
it's like what i don't know what to say
i've been having this feeling lately
where like i'm like am i
doing the the biden version of tds
where like everything that happens is
definitely his fault
and definitely part of a grand scheme
and definitely evidence that they're
trying to kill us
all and destroy the country one step at
a time right in front of our faces
yeah no eds yes they are no they're not
no you're not you're not you don't have
bite into arrangements i don't think i
don't have binders i don't think it's
biden though i think that there's
he's just a pawn that doesn't isn't
cognizant enough to be aware of what's
going on around him
well so so let's let's take a look at
this letter real quick and then i i do
think that we will
we'll lead off with that because that's
a really good point and i think the
answer is no
we don't have biden arrangements
syndrome i think some people do
absolutely
i think there's people who are building
careers off of like biden is always bad
no when when biden announced he was
moving up the vaccine schedule i
gave him credit i was like that's
fantastic absolutely uh
donald trump was the one who did all the
work for this donald trump deserves
credit for operation warp speed
joe biden saying we're gonna increase
production move the schedule it's a good
thing
it's not like he won a war or like ended
a war or got everybody rich or anything
but you know
i try to give credit where credit is due
no he started wars and made us all poor
right exactly yeah and that's bad stuff
yeah that's bad you know 2019 best
numbers of our lives jim cramer
whether you trust the guy or not but
anyway here's the letter and i'll read
i'll read to some of it so you get the
general idea
well i'll actually i'll read the
highlights because reading the whole
letter
they say quote election integrity
demands ensuring there is one legal vote
cast and counted per election
legal votes are identified by state
legislatures approved controls
using government ids verified signatures
etc etc they write
they have a huge list like let me read
this one
the mental and physical condition of the
commander-in-chief cannot be ignored
he must be able to quickly make accurate
national security decisions involving
life and limb anywhere
day or night recent democrat leadership
uh inquiries about nuclear code
procedures
sends a dangerous national security
signal to nuclear-armed adversaries
raising the question about who is in
charge we must always have an
unquestionable chain of command
100 we talked about this on this show
when the democrats were like maybe biden
shouldn't be the only one with nuclear
capabilities like
with the codes and it's like what are
you telling the world when you say that
true in anasha at a pressure what do you
think kim jong-un is thinking when you
watch joe biden say that
or when he sees joe biden go i'm going
to get in trouble if i answer questions
so i got to leave
how would you feel if you walked into a
tent in the middle of a war you were at
war
with your comrades and you walked into
uh a tent and joe biden was there the
general
and you were like what do we do and he's
like oh he'd be removed immediately
immediately immediately he has as far as
i know zero combat ex
zero military he would have gotten
fragged a long time ago hold on trump
trump doesn't have any combat experience
zero however you walk
in and donald trump is going we are not
going to allow them no excuse me we are
not letting him take that front i want
more soldiers there no it's quiet excuse
me and they're like okay okay
joe biden's going you know uh the the
one strategy
we got we ought to focus uh
anyway yeah that's when the guys take
them out that's when they say okay
grandpa come on you stumble and don't
i mean they walk you mean they walk him
out of the room yeah they remove him
from his position
right jessie kelly had a great tweet
about this today he's also going to be
live on jack murphy live tomorrow 12 15
jesse kelly
uh thank you the guests are getting
better i have some great guests coming
up as well
um and he's pointed out he's like look
if you're a bad guy out there in the
world this is your moment to make your
move
this is your moment to make your move
because there's nobody uh on watch
nobody seems to care and if they do care
they kind of want to help you you know
like it's you know it's a moment of
weakness you know what it feels like
it's like the
the democrats right now are the
equivalent of a bunch of
like miners who put on trench coats on
top of each other's shoulders and snuck
into a frat party
and so now they know that their the
amount of time they have in this party
is limited so they're like just grab as
much as you can and they're like
drinking and then like
you know the the the the frat leader guy
he's like some some you know douche bro
who's like yo what are these kids doing
here get them out of here
basically my analogy is yeah they're in
the system
there's no leadership it's wild and out
of control and they're extracting and
extracting and extracting and just like
watching the whole thing fall down
because they want to get as much as they
can before they get the boot because
they know they're getting the boot
and then bine's like i don't know man
give me six pounds
hold on biden is the grandpa they use to
sneak into the ball oh yeah
alcohol right these are my kids they're
all 50.
and they're like okay grandpa and then
you know did the generals
put their names behind this oh yeah yeah
that's legit any names that we know
let me see let's get some photos major
general joe arbuckle oh
arbuckle that's a name wow do you want
me to read all the names
yes i'm just kidding i guess a few maybe
uh i don't what does mg stand for major
general i think so
major general joseph t anderson uh
what's r-a-d-m philip uh uh
and selmo joseph arbuckle john eric
johnson yeah yeah there you go john w
bayless james best there's so many
titles in here like
charles bishop i'm not going to read
ourselves edward biggs richard tex brown
who they call him text the third
whoa he's a third or something that's
cool it doesn't sound like a very
diverse bunch
joe owens jimmy pappas hey jimmy pappas
huh paul mock
leonard f the coat do we have any john
poindexter
i don't know um i don't i don't know i
see a john white
that's the opposite oh yeah i don't know
how many women
uh no no women how many people of color
with no women no people color i just
obviously don't trust it
a lot of richards i don't know john's uh
ken hageman how many total 180 120. so
what are there 660 generals all across
the u.s military completely
and we're looking at that these are
these are these are these are retirees
oh they're all retired
okay that's still a third of the the
total number of general ship of the
united states
more more uh yeah well but they're
retired they're about they are retired
more people condemned trump
it was like 357 or whatever retired
officers who were like trump is bad
that was the easy that was the easy play
so let me let me tell you something
you do not have derangement syndrome for
criticizing body when he's doing bad
things
i mean did you criticize trump when
trump did bad things yes constantly
yeah well when trump fired thomak
missiles into syria uh
darren beat he fired mike michael anton
all kinds of bad things didn't fire a
bunch of people brought on john bolton
yeah no not anton now it's it's it's
it's very simple
uh we act asking this question we're
very actively trying to make sure we're
not just playing that game
you know yeah and that's actually a
weakness in terms of the
the cultural conflict the left doesn't
do that
there what happened remember remember
when joe biden was like bombing syria
and this woman she with a woman from new
york times was like waking up on sunday
and there's no tweets from trump oh
no they're so relaxed wasn't that
jennifer rubin oh reuben okay
and i'm like you know you we're just
watching the news seeing like you know
kids blow up and stuff but uh go to
sleep go to sleep
you've been sleeping the whole time
anyway so don't bother waking up you'll
only make a mess of it again if you
look rigorous investigation is not the
hallmark of the left i recently uh
tweeted out some information from
education on the left where the slide
said that if
you look at data and the only conclusion
that you come up with is that
this if you don't come up with the idea
that the system is broken
that for whatever reason that kids have
different outcomes the data is wrong the
system's broken or you're a bigot
that's it that sounds about right you're
a bigot i think that's okay
that's how you use data that's what
research is all about yeah so
uh to be critical of joe biden the way
that we were of donald trump i think is
not something that we're gonna see a lot
someone tweeted they uh they were like
it's been four months
and already we're dealing with all of
these crises
and then some some lefty responded with
how is this in any way
the result of biden policies and i was
like imagine living in that world
where you don't know what biden's been
doing and for those that are listening
who are like i bet tim's not even going
to give an example
joe biden rescinded the executive orders
from donald trump and issued 50 or so
executive wars on his own some of those
executive orders were the remain in
mexico policies which resulted in a poll
factor and now we have more migrant
children in detention
another thing that happened was that joe
biden reopened the homestead facility
and put more kids in cages
they don't seem to care about it aoc who
once at their concentration camps is now
saying
their their migrant what what did you
call them facilities with controversial
records
it's a big step up from uh concentration
camps
that's right two stars joe biden is also
proposing that we increase we extend the
unemployment benefits of 300
a week for for another large amount of
time or undetermined amount of time
and chamber of commerce commerce said
this is resulting in people walking off
the job and we need to stop it
11 republican governors have now said
they're not going to accept this money
because it's destroying the economy joe
biden is responsible for these things
it is joe biden's policies he restored
funding to
uh political factions in gaza and now
all of a sudden conflict is breaking out
i am not going to sit here and say look
at joe biden he's making moves on the
economy with mass spending the democrats
and republicans are responsible for that
last year
joe biden is now exacerbating it things
are getting worse joe biden
is telling people when it comes to
immigration
the the words of the president matter
but it's also his policies
these things are having an impact joe
biden goes in
and starts talking about israel and and
having to be responsible
and having you know having
accountability and then all of a sudden
now this whole thing is
is bubbling up i understand i can't
blame the president for israel and
palestine that's a huge conflict that
goes back a decent amount of time
but you look in manhattan when people
are beating each other in the streets
you look at the actions of the u.s
attorneys who have been cutting loose
the far-left extremists dropping felony
charges in the pacific northwest
and the violence is getting worse even
finally the local news is talking about
it so
there are just a few examples of what
joe biden has done which is causing very
serious consequences
and i'll tell you this tell me when he
says we are going to continue the
unemployment benefits 16
an hour and then you see all of this
crazy stuff happening with the exodus
from the workforce
and the left these these young
20-something dsa people democratic
socialists
don't understand math they're like yay
give us benefits we shouldn't have to
work at all it's like okay well if you
don't make stuff you don't get stuff
so if no one's making stuff then you got
no stuff to make or to buy to do
anything with
that's just some of it that's just thank
you for those examples tim i appreciate
that
it's fire you always have citations well
it's because i'm not just making things
up like i don't like joe biden
according to ballot pedia he signed 43
executive orders 16 presidential
memoranda 69 proclamations and 13
notices
on day one he made since he's been in
office dramatic
he took dramatic actions unprecedented
levels of executive orders and
memorandums
and now all of these things happening at
the same time surely it was a
coincidence
trump was just you know putting duct
tape over the holes and then as soon as
he left the duct tape popped off that's
what happened right it's all trump's
fault
no it's a busted machine or joe biden
got in
and said change change change change
change change change and
pop the board it's always an interesting
thing to see like when trump came into
office the economy was doing okay
and they're like can't be trump's fault
can't be trump trump didn't do it how
long how long into the presidency has
become theirs
but in this economy does take some time
the inflation was probably baked in
starting last year and it's getting
worse now with these new packages
but the decisions that he made around
the executive orders and foreign policy
changes and
and immigration changes and things like
that those are huge impactful right now
policy changes stephen miller for all
the things you want to criticize that
guy for he crafted
an immigration policy that slowed the
flow of refugees or of of uh illegal
immigrants it slowed
the massing of immigrants at the border
it slowed the number of kids
in the cages and the detention centers
and the two-star hotels depending on
who's talking
it slowed all that stuff they rescind
all of it and now it just blows
up joe biden was uh under his policies
allowing illegal immigrants to come in
who are coveted positive and then they
were immediately released into texas at
a time when you
could not travel you could not go to
restaurants that was the
biggest punch in the gut the spit in the
face to the american people
we gotta we gotta we gotta ban travel to
india so seth joe biden
media says that's a okay that's not
racist well joe biden said it was
xenophobic after trump ban to travel to
china
we get it joe biden and the media are
hypocrites they want political power
now that they got into the party they
are extracting from the system and
watching it burn before us
did kamala harris go down to the border
when she was tasked with dealing with
the crisis
no she laughed at the reporter who asked
her she openly
i'm not going down there oh as if to say
you are a
stupid piece of garbage for thinking i
would ever do anything to serve the
american people i don't stay at two star
hotels
get the hell out of here you're coming
here is heaven forbid she has to
actually go and look at those
those pores i think i have i have kamala
harris
arrangement syndrome kamala harris
responded to that reporter
uh the only poor people i'm interested
in seeing are the people who attend to
my pores at the spa
it's a futurama i like how you've been
using the word pores i mean i don't
really like it but i feel like 21st
century that might become derogatory
yeah that's that's the point i'm mocking
those people for call for
for you know there's no room for sarcasm
here i know right
of course terrifying because it really
is a class issue and in the future
they may really look at the pores like
it's a race of people i i
can't when watching kamala harris laugh
in the face of that reporter for asking
if she would if she would go to the
border
kamala harris protested the homestead
facility aoc protested this
the biden administration reopened the
facility where the children were being
detained now i understand that
i did not go after biden for that what
i'm criticizing is the double standard
you need to have kids somewhere when
trump was doing i was like what are we
going to do just leave the kids in the
desert
you got to put them somewhere and we
gotta we can do better i suppose
but how were you gonna protest that then
be part of the administration that
reopens it and when someone says will
you go to the border you laugh
in their face about not to defend that
psycho
but it's clear that her laughter
is a sign of her own cognitive
dissonance right it's clearly when she's
challenged she's uncomfortable she knows
she's wrong or she doesn't know the
answer or whatever it is she just
cackles because she knows she's
caught of course i don't i don't the
question was will you go down to the
border
she wasn't caught on anything she just
started laughing she hasn't been
she's not prioritizing that one this was
this was right when biden was like
i'm tasking commodores dealing with this
she was boarding a plane they were like
will you be heading down to the border
and she laughed and said not today
it's like she's the wicked witch of the
west you think i would actually care for
these children
give me your political power that's what
she does she just needs a tiny bit of
makeup can we get a meme of like her
we need her to like to merge her face
with the emperor you know
yeah the mace windu scene
oh my gosh i'm sure it's out there like
slowly turns into kamal and then back
into
like a deep fake that's what she wants
and joe biden is just sitting there like
you know uh somebody tweeted my favorite
quote from joe biden my favorite
presidential quote from joe biden and
he's like
i can't i don't remember the exact quote
but he says something like you know the
one way
to get ahead and with the dream and to
fight with
to go anyway that was really i was about
as exhilarating
then as it was now anyway like what were
you
willing to say all right well donald
trump is back my friend check this out
oh god from fox news trump mocks
comparisons of biden to jimmy carter
the current president is worse yep this
is actually really good
trump won't stop emailing me i don't
know about you guys he loves you
like four emails from trump yesterday
you got to sign up for this i'm like
trump what are you doing and one of them
was like i went golfing today and i was
like that's fantastic i
don't want i don't need this but i sent
an email and he was like
he basically said stop comparing biden
to jimmy carter well he said while jimmy
carter failed in the face of many crises
joe biden is making the crisis and i'm
like it's not wrong
it's actually a good it's actually a
good point uh
joe biden's policies are resulting in a
lot of these things let me let me show
you some of this
what he said quote i see that everybody
is comparing joe biden to jimmy carter
it would seem to me that is very unfair
to jimmy carter
jimmy mishandled crisis after crisis but
biden has created christ after crisis
first there was the biden border crisis
that he refuses to call crisis
then the economic crisis then the biden
israel crisis another abiding gas crisis
and those are all policies those are all
the positions of the obama
administration
joe biden has had the worst start of any
president in u.s history
and someday they will compare future
disasters to the baby administration but
no
jimmy was better he added republicans
have said the crisis the border is a
direct result of biden's reversal of
trump air migration policies
the biden admin has in turn so the
problem is rooted in trump's strict
immigration policies
and human rights abuses you know what's
funny about that
trump's not president anymore the buck
stops with you
when bad things were happening with war
people were like yo but
trump inherited those wars and i was
like trump's president
the buck stops at the president i'm not
going to pretend you know
i get it obama inherited the war from
bush obama still did messed up stuff
trump inherited the war from from obama
trump didn't create more worse
trump withdrawal out of the troops those
are good things trump still did some
messed up stuff
eight-year-old american girls killed in
a commando rate almost immediately when
trump got elected
but man now that they're playing this
game where
when trump got in and the economy was
booming 2019 best numbers of our lives
they're like no no it's not trump it's
not trump obama created this economy
and now the economy is really bad it's
trump's fault well i think the economy
was in a bubble
when trump came in well there was just a
mass printing raid
since 2008 really we've just seen the
money increase increasing
it was the last year of trump where
really before before it exploded and now
well now it's just it's still expanding
it's just bubbling super fast
unemployment was very low gdp was very
high stock market was very high
uh people had jobs low end wages were
going up and this was 2019 this was
before covert this was before the
trillions and trillions and trillions of
dollars it was long enough into trump's
presidency
that you couldn't give all the credit to
obama it was three years in
it was clear that trump crafted an
economy that worked for the market
and worked for the lowest wage earners
in america
but trump mishandled kovid the crisis
politically he didn't mishandle it in
terms of the general approach to how you
would how you would handle the
the pandemic simply because we don't
have a control country by which we could
measure
what would have been good or bad it was
a novel virus
trump took action i thought it was good
but politically democrats
were and republicans were all printing
money like crazy democrats and
republicans are the ones who created
this unemployment stimulus thing
and you had some like thomas i think it
was thomas massey right who was like
don't give people money not to work oh
yeah but republicans and democrats where
was trump
trump was very supportive of a lot of
the stuff trump was very much like print
more money give the people more money
yeah
and now the bill comes due however i'm
not going to fault trump
for a pandemic and an emergency
the problem is what was happening was
across the board
democrats and republicans trump
everybody was like i don't know what
we're doing the governors were like
cuomo was like maybe i just killed 15
000 people and
so trump could have done politically a
lot better and the reason i say this
trump should have fired a lot of people
he shouldn't have fired some people
he should have been stricter with some
people and so i feel like when the
pandemic hit
and you saw the violation of
constitutional rights trump could have
the federal government could have
intervened but trump didn't do a lot of
these things
he didn't shut down the riots the riots
are still happening right
so a lot of the stuff we are seeing are
uh uh i should say
uh some of it does come from from trump
however
joe budden has been president now for
just about four months he has enacted
tons of policies
and the and the major problems we're
seeing are direct result of democrat
pushes
some with republicans but the the border
policies
the conflict in the middle east economic
crisis gas shortages
where's the fbi been why why wh
this cyber attack on colonial fbi is too
busy tracking down grandmas
who took a tour through the capitol on
the wrong day that is biden's
administration who was prioritizing
going after
bumbling dotards who walked in and i
mean it look i get it the people who
stormed in were like bashing cops
yes arrest those people but they're
actually going after like they got one
guy and it's like the door was open he
was confused and he walked and they're
like and now you go to prison
that's what they're focusing on and our
gas pipelines are being just shut down
great great thanks thanks guys i
appreciate it as if this gas
uh pipeline shutdown is going to be an
isolated event
no i expect the worst hope for the best
expect the worst if you want to survive
it is it is a
it is a plausible promise that has been
confirmed uh that will feed a
decentralized open source
uh activity in this manner that it's
clear now that you can
independently attack a uh would you say
independently attack uh a pipeline and
shut it down cause this kind of
disruption it's gonna inspire other
people to do the same thing yesterday
they said people were drilling into the
pipelines
eco-terrorists were going up to the
pipelines like drilling a hole in it
somewhere along the champions league
that's that no that's like there was
speculation about that oh
yeah i don't know for sure i was
jokingly whispering bitcoin
that's that was the joke i didn't say
buy bitcoin i just had bitcoin
not giving any financial advice but
that's bitcoin backwards
that's really hard weird no i need to
stop with that yeah
because i don't think firstly i don't
think it's biden's fault that's been
going on for a hundred years almost
no it is sad and terrifying did you guys
see the video of the rockets
flying into town an iron dome yeah
yeah it's it's it's it's uh uh i i don't
wanna i don't wanna pretend like biden
takes full responsibility for a
conflict that's been going on for a long
time but a lack of leadership
first we can just say biden does not
have the mental ability
to lead at a crisis right now for what's
going on
more importantly you can look to people
like ben shapiro who point out that joe
biden started funding a bunch of these
palestinian groups and then all of a
sudden we get a
missile barrage a few months in oh i
think the idea here is that trump was
very clear in his support for israel it
was very clear they were working hard to
secure israel and it was very clear that
they were going to support israel and
doing anything that they had to do to
defend themselves
and now that he is gone there is
weakness in the white house
at best at worst there is a collaborator
in the white house uh you know if you're
from the israeli perspective
and so they have now been inspired to
begin hostilities again because the uh
sort of the threat matrix is is out of
balance where it was in balance when
trump was there and i i you know
look i understand there's a big conflict
i understand people are like you know
what you're talking about as soon as you
criticize anything
when i watch videos of rocket fires
which are random and are hitting buses
in schools
civilian targets and then israel does
surgical strikes on select targets
which sometimes is civilian targets
because hamas
and you know these groups are using them
it's a big difference
i understand and and i hear from the the
left of the pro-palestinian side saying
you know they have right to defend
themselves and i'm like i don't know if
that extends to like blowing up a school
and they say the same thing about israel
i'm like maybe you need to stop the
people from going into schools and using
them as missile bases i don't know i
don't know
you know but i'll put it this way okay
all right i'll step back
i i don't know the depth of this
conference there's a lot of people much
better verse
than i it goes back to like the crusades
i mean it was like a port a trade port
yeah
1000 a.d probably even before that but
it you know now there's the suez canal
so it kind of protects that the canal
which is the
shipping line of the world basically
it's biden's fault man look
the end of the trump administration was
the abraham accords and you had a bunch
of arab nations
signing peace peace deals with israel
and that was huge and there was a lot of
speculation
that this would put pressure on these
extremist groups that are firing rockets
into israel to stop
because once they do things can start to
normalize that was the hope i suppose
but there's a lot of people who are like
it doesn't matter because
israel is settler colonialism and they
should be you know removed or whatever
and so i actually see these memes from
any of these leftists saying israel
should be removed outright because
they're colonists
and they're straight up saying the
people in israel shouldn't get say in it
at all and i'm like
come on i understand there's a conflict
i understand you think your side is
right
but how do we resolve this by saying one
side must be purged from the land that's
insane
it can't be you could go if i could go
back 150 years and say maybe we should
build israel in a different place
because they were originally going to do
it in northeast africa
and then i think it was the balfour
declaration they said they were gonna
well basically what happened was world
war one
the arabs were on the side of the
ottomans and well i i look i got i'm
sorry
we'll check this out i understand but i
don't want to re i don't want to get
into
this i don't think anyone here has
enough knowledge on the israel
palestinian conflict the issue is a
little bit the issue is joe biden
and his ability to lead and the middle
east and foreign policy not the history
of israel and why
one side is right one side is wrong my
point is i don't think
i don't think that removing one side is
the way i agree with you
it's what it is there's a bunch of
people living there now and so i don't
know what the solution is
i can tell you that under trump he
seemed to be getting a hold on a lot of
the conflict in the middle east
and they hated him for it you know why
well in my opinion the
military-industrial complex types these
big weapons manufacturers
and the neocons which are now the
democrats
needed conflict in the middle east to
justify
expansion and occupation not in israel
in afghanistan iraq they want to go
after iran john bolton was like we're
going to celebrate next year in tehran
and everyone's like yay
and that was trump who brought that guy
in they want that but how do you justify
occupation in the middle east when
there's peace
well that was bad trump bringing peace
to these countries oh
no now how are we going to sell the
american people that we're going to have
more weapons
it wasn't it wasn't peace in the west
bank when he
the the israelis signed declarations of
uae and remember when donald trump said
they were going to move the embassy to
jerusalem and they were like it's going
to be the end it's going to be
right nothing because the palestinians
are like jerusalem is our holy city so
to move
the the israeli american embassy to the
the jewish
the israeli version the point is
insulting i don't know
the the democrats are the neocons
yeah the neocons moved to the democratic
party now we got what's the story 100
republicans are like we're going to quit
the gop because of trump and say okay go
go join the democrats and be a pro-war
please do
seriously yeah seriously and they uh
they want war
joe biden wants war like we get news
reports as soon as joe biden's in that
movement into syria soldiers are moving
through
you know northeastern syria and i think
they want the conflict
and i think what's happening with israel
is good for them because they can
justify
why we should have war in the middle
east and it's it's
it's for a lot of reasons it's for
energy expansion it's for control of the
region
but you need the american people to
support it so this conflict between
israel and palestine is great for
democrats joe biden
what did he come out and say just
recently israel has a right to defend
itself
yeah it's weird because if you now we're
going to send more money to them our
ally
and we're going to have more conflict
which allows us to say we got to send
more missiles over there and occupy the
area
if you stick a person in a bear cage
with a hundred hungry bears and then
you're like
that human needs to defend himself well
like yeah you didn't need to put him in
the bear cage but you did
and you're right if you want him to
survive he needs to defend himself
that's kind of the situation of israel
right now well i'm just saying that
the conflict is good for those who want
to sell weapons
exactly and and have us energy right
energy dependent on another region
that's right that's right right so like
the keystone
shutdown not really aggressively
defending this uh pipeline attack
possibly shutting down another uh
pipeline in michigan
all these things are disrupting our
energy supplies we need oil where can we
get it we don't have it here
so i guess we got to go get it in we
could try blowing up kids in the middle
east
i hear that's a policy of the time so
wait a second we can sell missiles
blow up kids and get expensive money
perfect
i'm in and donald trump is like
americans should have jobs
right and the democrats are like can we
blow up kids
now here's one of the problems with
trump is that first of all why
why bolton you know who gave him that
advice that was the stupidest thing
i'm gonna hire this [ __ ] because he saw
him on tv a lot yeah that's not a joke
yeah yep uh fox news and the other
problem is when he was pressured into
the military actions he was pressured
into
that was he just i look trump is
an arrogant guy he's full of himself he
knows what he wants but when it came to
things he wasn't an expert on he
deferred to people who are stupid
and then he was like i guess i'll fire
missiles and the news media loved it
they were like trump is presidential now
bombing children you know i remember
that day very vividly because i also
then went down to the white house to
cover
a alt-right richard spencer jason
kessler-led protest
against trump that day because of the
syrian missile strikes and then antifa
showed up i was i ended up in the middle
between these two
parties fighting i'm standing there
taking pictures
someone else took a picture of me taking
pictures of of uh
spencer and kessler and then posted that
later saying claiming that was that i
was a nazi
yeah yeah yeah but uh i remember that
very clearly but also trump deferred
on covet as well that's right and and
yet
you know the media of course the fouchy
of all they weren't really pleased about
that but i thought actually
in that case that he deferred to the
experts as well as anybody could have
deferred to the federalist system
deferred to the
states he shouldn't have when it came to
the
quote-unquote are you gonna do what are
you gonna do you don't know anything
about this and you've got a guy that
everybody's saying
fire them all and then what find other
experts yep
i mean it sounds i would it sounds that
easy dude no
i i understand it's not as easy
especially when they were obstructing
they wouldn't confirm a lot of his
cabinet position
the peop you know they wouldn't confirm
a lot of people for his cabinet but
trump should have just went you know i
guess he thought he was going to win
another term
and so that was the goal play it
moderate or maybe he thought he was
helping the american people that was the
right thing no no
i mean like sure but he also why didn't
he just go and fire fauci why didn't he
send in the troops
re-election you you could only do so
much in your first room or second term
you get more leeway because
this is it do what you got to do but
trump was aiming for the win
i mean he got 10 million more votes
second time around
but you know what i refer to the biden
voters as it was it was a political
drive-by
these people don't care about politics
at all the people i know who voted for
biden
they're gone they're posting pictures of
the bread they made they voted for this
guy
they come in and they're like donald
trump is the fastest and anyway we gotta
vote for joe biden then they do
now they're gone they don't watch cnn
they don't watch msnbc anymore they're
gone
and i'm sitting here and we're sitting
here like well the world's on fire where
are they at now to take responsibility
for what they just did
none no responsibility and of course
when they'll filter it through their
their mental model of the world they
won't make any connection to any of
their behavior they're voting they're
supporting
these policies that leads to all these
terrible outcomes and now we're
we're all left here holding the bag and
hey but good news
there's just three years and eight
months left
jack yeah i hear trump is considering
running again four years from now yeah
is that how it works
i hate that it is like a reality show
this whole political
circus where it's like um two years out
there's gonna be non-stop media coverage
about who's running for office again
like is that really what the
what the human race cares about are you
kidding there's so much
technology and advancements that we can
make on our own
because because in reality tv the
democrats want to burn the system to the
ground
they want to extract what they can while
they can
and so they have very limited power
right now the the senate by a tiebreaker
vote that's it
they have what like 11 seats in in
congress and they don't have the supreme
court except by exertion of media
pressure
and they have the president who is just
not all with it and they're like can we
just
squeeze the last little bit of you know
it's like you got extra virgin olive oil
this is like the opposite of that it's
like
you don't think that they're setting
themselves in their mind you don't think
that they've thought that they've won
the last contested election that the
demographics are going to give them the
pres you know all the governments for
forever
they're going to bring in 30 million new
voters and they're settling in
this is the new democratic no way are
you do you think that if that were true
joe biden would have would have fired
off what he's like 50
63 or was it 53 memorandums and
executive orders
that was a panic that was him being like
just just
sign it sign it sign it sign it sign it
sign it before it's too late
yeah because the political drive-by the
people who ca that's why i'm saying
i don't think trump should run in 2024 i
think should desantis should
yeah they'll smear desantis they'll
smear any republican runs
but trump is a ball of fire that they
need
to trigger the the politically
uninitiated
desantis comes out could you imagine
someone going like their grandma and
being like this this santas guy's a nazi
she'll go
who but trump i know trump from the
apprentice
yeah he said all those nasty things oh
no they know who trump is
they came out they hated the guy
desantis are gonna be like i don't know
but that's so weird because
everybody loved trump until the day he
vote he decided to run for office
oprah jesse jackson all those guys loved
him pictures come on my show
put my arms around you i love you donald
trump's my boy and he was too
big and he and and you know a lot of
what he did helped him a lot of what he
did hurt him but it's created this
permanent ball of fire
if trump came back cnn would start
crying
praising the lord i thought we were
gonna have to lay everyone off thank god
trump is back
if it's desantis they're gonna be like
desantis is bad
and people are gonna be like i don't
know who that is i don't care where are
they gonna they're gonna have to go
beyond
hitler right like mecca hitler
desantis isn't just hitler he's trump
he's trump that's got to be the new
highest level smear
right i guess if you've already called
someone hillary look i'm i'm
i'm not concerned right now about where
we're at in 2022 or 2024
no it may be the case that democrats are
you know
not you know they're taking a little
dirt hole to sit in like a little
chicken or something they're going to
get ready for their dirt bath
you and your chickens that's right
they're getting really big in them early
right
out there watching them look you look at
the story with like liz cheney
and the political world is completely
irrelevant right now when we're dealing
with all these crises
now i i shouldn't say completely
obviously
these things will have ramifications
moving forward into the political space
but what do people really care about
think about gotcha he's on your arm
jackson's got stink bugged here we go i
don't throw him on me
i eat it throwing bugs the chickens love
them they're like they just
they they fight over them oh yeah and
they they will pick them up
and pull them from each other's mouths
imagine being the stink bug and being
picked by a chicken and they're all just
like ripping your
limbs up all right all right check us
out okay let's talk about real news
from the daily mail inflation hits
highest rate since 2008.
the price of milk bread meat and energy
rose 4.2 percent this year
as the economy recovers from covert oh
is that what they're saying oh but is it
rebounding too
fast i love this thing where they're
they're starting they're claiming
inflation isn't actually that high it's
an illusion because
it was frozen last year because of covet
and now it's just coming back it's all
coming back
no it isn't people don't have jobs
they're not working what do you mean
it's coming back
there's signs across the board people
like i don't want to work here i'm not
going to work
there's 8.1 million job openings and
they could only fill 266
000 wow you call that recovering from
covid no the economy is in flames and
joe biden's like
come on man do more nobody should work
uh you know
workers of the world unite take take
money from the rich the thing about
inflation is it's not a static number it
didn't like land here and this is where
it's at it's a momentous force so
it's passing through four point two
percent where does it say
four point two percent it's passing
through that on its way to another
number
it's moving there was something i was
told earlier that there were a bunch of
boxes
that were very heavy for you that
arrived that would be flour how much
uh 30 40 pounds four or four
pounds of flour something like that
that's that no 160 pounds
170 pounds why did you buy that because
you can freeze it
and it's available to get it now before
there's a run on it i have a really
important side note about this oh do you
want to know who moved these boxes of
flowers
this afternoon it was lydia lydia
i parked in the parking lot and walked
right past ten boxes
oh that was a pizza that was beans in
her eyes so we're getting prepped so
yeah we are but i do want to clarify
yeah it sounds like a lot that ian
bought but there's what like 14 people
that come through here
yeah and so we're not we're not we're
not actually buying bread from the store
we don't do it ian just starts a loaf of
bread with fresh ingredients
everything's so good you got about five
or six days out of it if
everybody eats it with money on election
night 2016 i made baguettes that night
throughout the election
man well so so we're not doing a segment
on bread
oh sorry we're just talking about
inflation inflation
and panic buying yeah so
there you go i don't i don't think it's
fair to say it's panic buying when
everyone decides to go get gas at the
same time
it's not a panic if you're like oh man
what's going on the news i'm at half a
tank i better you know top off because i
got work tomorrow common sense that's
just like normal things but there are
videos of people doing
there's a video of like a guy with with
a bunch of plastic bags full of gasoline
in his trunk
you see this i did tied off and then and
then what is it the product consumer
safety
you know twitter was like please do not
fill up plastic bags with gasoline
i can confirm i did not panic by the 150
pounds of flour
okay i just saw that it was available
and thought what a boon
what a luxury that i have as a human to
have access to 150 pounds of organic
white flour
i want it now i can freeze it it'll last
for years and years get it
and then i realized after well if
there's a panic run
those things become you only buy four
you can only buy 20 pounds of it now
so i'm glad i got it now so that's kind
of like panic buying dude but i wasn't
in a panic when i bought it i just
thought no no no no
that's the issue is that when the prices
start skyrocketing
and inflation is going up people are
like okay look i got 10 bucks right now
tomorrow it's gonna have the buying
power of five bucks then i mean honestly
the ten bucks today is the buying power
of like what like less than a cent
the ten bucks is like borderline
worthless compared to 100 years ago
so people are like i better spend the
money now because
you know it's not i'm not going to buy
anything with it tomorrow so then
everybody says
all right bread milk energy so what are
people doing they're buying
tons of stuff this causes product
shortages and it causes
more inflation it works both ways too
imagine you're a guy that's got a
warehouse full of stuff you can sell
today for 10 or tomorrow for 12.
there was a craigslist post that went
viral where somebody was like a couple
weeks ago i bought a bunch of gas for
you know my machines or whatever
16 a gallon come by and i'll i'll top
you off or something like that
people are hoarding gas now and trying
to exploit the crisis
because sometimes people a lot of people
are just bad people you know
is that is that a bad person or are they
providing liquidity in a time of crisis
which is a service that people want
because they're freely engaging in the
buying and selling of that commodity
which they could not get anywhere else
except for that price this is the same
concept behind uber surge pricing
which i fully support i've gotten
totally screwed by it i've paid 200
for a 20 cab ride before because there's
no other cars and it was a surge time
but i paid for it because it's not the
only way to get the car
i i wouldn't say it's the exactly the
same thing right going to a gas station
when you when you know there's going to
be a crisis and buying
by buying as much as possible to then
resell it right off right off the bat
i'm not a fan of in some areas people
complain about
price gouging on like water right
there'll be a storm and then someone
will be like five dollars for a bottle
of water and i'm like that's fantastic
you know why
if you buy a bunch of water and drive it
into a disaster
you're taking risk you're buying things
you can solve for what you want to solve
for that's different that's the same as
the guy
no it is who took it back to him no no
he took on the risk that would be going
to the gas station right before the
hurricane it's buying all their water
and then standing outside being like now
it's five bucks
that's not providing a service and
alleviating any tensions that's
exploiting the crisis
if you're bringing so when we saw people
got they got in trouble because they
brought water into disaster areas and
sold it for like five bucks a bottle and
i'm like there'd be no water there
somebody decided to drive into the
disaster taking risks to bring water to
these people
it costs money taking taking water from
the store
and then going outside and doubling the
cost of it you're just exploiting people
who are in a crisis
sure i'm not sure fine i guess if you're
a capitalist you're probably alive
but that guy with the gas could have
been taking it 100 miles away to a place
where they didn't have any gas
you don't know that we just don't see
seeing videos of people filling up like
laundry tubs with gasoline look as
somebody who went to the gas station
twice today to make sure i had a full
tank to drive round trip all the way out
here and make sure i can take my kids
around school tomorrow and whatever
i like was thinking maybe i should have
trash bags full of gas in my car too
because because if i can't take my kids
places
or i can't pick them up then i don't get
to see my children
you're not filling up trash bags of gas
to then resell for five times the price
at the same location okay you got to
wonder when does it become predatory i
guess because
there's nothing wrong with marking up
your your product in if someone needs it
you know like if
the the story of the umbrella salesman
that will sell the umbrellas for a
dollar until it rains and then they're
twenty dollars each
or ten dollars each that's fine and they
still sell all the umbrellas that's fine
um same with water when there's a crisis
you sell the water for a markup of 500
whatever i'm saying that if you walked
into walgreens and bought all their
umbrellas
and then stood outside because you knew
it was going to rain and then sold them
for double the cost i think that's
screwed up
yeah that's actually illegal in the
stock market to buy out an entire
service and then relist it
i'm just saying like you you know that
like you're taking advantage of people
you're not providing anything for
society you're not producing
you're literally standing in front of
the store selling what you just bought
and
stripping money away from people because
they're in need i'm not a fan of that
i'm not
i'm not a fan of people who produce
nothing and then can take away from
people who do work
i think it's funny because i don't i
don't think that should be like a left
position
because i'm pretty sure trump supporters
are very much in favor of protecting
workers rights and their right to own
property and freely trade and all that
stuff
really trade in this and so i'm not
saying they can't do it i'm just saying
i think it's screwed up i wouldn't do it
i don't think it's illegal to resell gas
for like you know was like three bucks a
gallon five dollars
you know uh five times as much 16 a
gallon
i think that's screwed up to do yeah i
think it's taken it's exploiting people
but
if it's illegal it's illegal i guess i
don't know i'm just saying if you if he
brought the gasoline to some place
and he was like look i had a tank for
this reason i'm gonna bring it into this
area
if you bought a bunch of gas in west
virginia where there's gas and drove it
into north carolina and sold it for 16
a gallon i got no problem you're
bringing a product to people who are in
desperate need
and you're taking a risk you can charge
whatever you want for it it's yours
if you're buying it from the gas station
and then going all right
now if you want guests i got it all i'm
like dude screw you
you know that's messed up i think
michael brown was doing that with
cigarettes
part of why the cops he was on lucy's
different so he like would go to the
store
buy a pack for 12 bucks and then he'd
come out and sell him for a dollar a
piece isn't that what he was doing
that's not michael brown michael brown
was was trying to was trying to steal
cigarillos or something
you're talking about eric garner oh god
eric garner people look not everybody
wants a full pack of cigarettes
right so imagine this imagine if you had
a pack of cigarettes and i was like yo
can i get a cigar for you and you were
like uh give me a dollar i bet okay yeah
that's what he was doing but he
was standing right outside the store
where he bought him and the stores don't
like to tell lucy's that way
because then people won't buy a pack of
cigarettes but
it's it's not the same thing he's not
exploiting crisis he's exploiting
in that instance that people don't want
a full pack of cigarettes so i i get it
it's it's a nuisance to the business
but it's not the same thing if you're
right outside the door if he bought
all of the cigarettes and then when
people were like i need a series like
too bad they're all mine now you got to
pay double
you need a license to sell tobacco um i
don't know about
gas it's different or water i don't
think it's different
it's it's water someone going into a
place and taking
so that no one else can buy it and then
demanding more from other people age old
the richest can go and buy up all the
resources and then resell them for more
expensive and that's been outlawed
i'm i don't know the exact laws but i
know that that's not if you call it free
trade but that means it's definitely
there's oversight it doesn't mean anyone
can sell it
it's called a monopoly you're not
supposed to be able to have monopolies
yes it's called monopoly when you buy up
all the stuff and can raise the price
because there's no other competitors in
your market
and when there's chaos in the lack of
oversight because of disaster then
how do you how do you track it you
really it's challenging
that's a challenge well you know what
would happen to that guy if if it's like
uh the only reason
people ought to do this because the
government protects them that's that's
the reality
do you know you know imagine if there
was no police and some guy pulls up to a
gas station and fills up you know a
bunch of
five-gallon tanks then he says he puts
it up and it's like out of order and
then he turns around with a smile on his
face and says
it was three bucks now it's 16. you know
what's gonna happen
they're gonna walk up and they're gonna
take it from him you can't get his ass
kicked yeah that wouldn't i mean he'd be
like hey don't take my guess they'd be
like you can't do anything about it
thanks for the free guess
if that that's what so the government
protects that guy when he does it that's
the problem
because if it was truly just a more
libertarian or free market
yeah that guy would be able to do that
they'd be like i ain't playing that game
with you
but the police would be there in two
seconds to defend him and his property
and so
it's a hybrid system that allows him to
exploit people this way
kind of only about a social worker to
distribute all the gasoline equally
amongst
all of the little birdies in the nest
hey man first come first serve you go to
the gas station you got cash you can buy
it
you fill up your tank that makes sense i
think if you pull up and you got a 10
gallon a real red canister and you're
like look i'm filling it up because i
got a lawnmower or whatever i think
that's fine too
and people are freaking out over that
there's stories where like a woman you
know out here went to a gas station and
she had
she filled up her car and then filled up
like a five gallon thing and people were
screaming you're hoarding
don't steal our guests and she's like i
got a lawnmower this is so
dumb are people yelling at the guys in
the suvs who have a 25 gallon tank and
just saying hey okay to the fiesta with
the 12 gallon tank right the yelling at
those guys the whole thing is dumb the
whole thing is
but but filling up like 10 tanks and
then being like now it's 16
that's something else so i kind of i'm
kind of like maybe we need to get rid of
the police in that regard too
because then people wouldn't do it
because they'd be worried about their
neighbors
right now the cops protect them if you
actually had to worry about
upsetting offending or or wronging your
neighbors
law is less relevant what's more
relevant is whether or not you're being
a good person well unless you have like
bodyguards and a bunch of weapons and
then you decide to charge 30
a gallon for the gas that you just
bought up yeah it's still wrong uh 50
people
if there's a hundred cars yeah how many
bodyguards are going to need to stop a
hundred angry people when you take all
their gas away seven that are fully
armed nah it's not going to happen
if they're not armed they can't do
anything they have an armed force and
you've got armed populations in a lot of
these states a lot of them so you can
have a bodyguard but if you start
stealing the gas from 100 people waiting
dude if i'm waiting on
stealing if you buy it yeah i'm sorry i
don't i don't agree you just got there
first
advocate here i'm talking about a guy
who's filling up 16 tanks
you know and taking all the capitalism
no i think it is illegal to do stuff
like that
right so the point is in a community
without protection of the government
that wouldn't happen a guy's gonna get
out of his car and he's gonna have a gun
too
you know it's a it's it's up in the air
what would happen because
it might not happen there might be like
hey you can't do that to us this is our
society or it might be like he's more
powerful
and he's like i can do whatever i want
to you this is my society and then
they're like uh i have nothing i'll work
for you bro we have a second amendment
people in these states have guns
you can have 10 bodyguards but if a
hundred people got out of their cars and
they're screaming
i don't think those body guards might
stick around for much longer it's not so
simple man
the only reason people are awaited
people are able to do these things is
because the government protects them
when they do it
otherwise they would be terrified of the
riotous mob
that's coming to basically take their
stuff i don't i think it's more who has
the
the most force not the government almost
like
like if if someone back in the day had
all the money and wanted to buy up all
the resources and hire all the military
and there was no government then they
would be the new government
sort of in a lot of ways but they still
deal with with death and conflict
from people who resist now there's a
monopoly on violence the government has
and they allow people to do this stuff
and regular citizens won't do anything
about it because they know they can't
because the cops will come and shut it
down and the courts will shut it down
if it was just a system where people
were like don't wrong me and i won't
wrong you
and there was a shared moral framework
we wouldn't be dealing with that kind of
stuff
people get like strung up in cities and
it's different you know we need a rule
of law we need uh
fair and just courts now what we're
dealing with is everybody who hates
everybody else or doesn't care
completely indifferent so they're like i
don't know you i don't care about you i
don't care if you're sick i don't care
if you need insulin i'm gonna take and
i'm gonna keep
so now everyone's just everyone every
man for himself and you can't you can't
function that way
it's funny because the left are
collectivists
but they don't actually care about the
true collective like the country the
community
so they claim to be but they're only
collectivists with their tribe who try
to seize power from others
whereas conservatives are collectivists
in the sense they believe in the nation
not every conservative i guess but most
conservatives are nationalists
and so that's about we as a country
working together
agreeing on certain things functioning
together having certain respect for each
other and letting people live
the problem is the culture war is two
different moral frameworks the left
doesn't care about anything i like the
individual versus collective mentality
because if i care about you
and you and you i care about us as a
collective
because i care about the individuals but
if i just care about the collective
you become like nameless faces to me and
all i care about is what we do as a
group that's the danger of collectivism
and then they think you should be
punished because someone in the house
did something
it's the sins of the father i suppose i
don't know look man inflation's going up
so we're buying bitcoin i guess i think
yeah the only we got a gas shortage we
got food shortage we got
all kinds of shortages the only thing we
know about shortage of is dollars
dollars out there we got too much
dollars chasing everything everywhere
and you know the sad scary part is
is that mmt modern monetary theory is
making headway into the government and
somebody somewhere up there
right now is saying oh inflation's going
up well the way mmt
described or prescribes to deal with
inflation how you do that
raise taxes baby that's what they want
to do yeah raising taxes
is how you control inflation according
to modern
monetary theory so keep an eye out for
that guys after all this
skyrocketing gas prices skyrocketing
food prices
inflation everywhere and guess what
they're going to do to fit to fix it
raise your taxes on top of it yeah
because they have to compensate for the
fact that printing money like crazy they
got to soak it up
out of the economy yep yeah the us is
rotten
uh it's by bitcoin it's rotted to the
core
and it's it's falling apart and it's
getting worse every day and the scary
thing is watching what we talked about
last year
happening right now it's all happening
we were we were all saying the bill will
come due on the mass printing of this
money
and i said look if we printed the money
and gave gave it to everybody at least
we're borrowing from ourselves
if they were like we're gonna you know
three trillion dollars and it goes
evenly amongst all americans
that's free tax free to engage in
commerce i'm like
it's going to cause inflation but at
least we're borrowing the money from
ourselves
the problem there is a lot of people who
don't work people who do but
there's a pandemic and we agree we're
going to work with each other and we're
a country that must survive and work
together
i accept these things they didn't do
that though they were giving it to big
businesses
i first came on the show one february of
2010 january 2020 january 2020 yeah
and uh we've been talking about this
we've been talking about what happened
through corona we've been talking about
what would happen if biden took office
we've been talking about all these
things and all the things that we talked
about are actually happening and worse
and i still can't believe it even though
we talked about it predicted it said it
was going to happen and now it's
actually worse
i should have bought bitcoin it's the
beauty of physics man you you calculate
where the ball is going to be when you
throw it at that
velocity in that direction and it lands
there and that's basically what we did
with this
economy i mean it's it's blatantly
obvious that if you print money
in may of 2020 that in february of 2021
you're going to see an inflation spike
all right well let's let's so we got the
democrats with the border crisis
economic crisis we got the mass exodus
from the workforce we got
israel palestine democrats toronto roll
what's the next big thing the democrats
have been calling for
hillary clinton gave an interview about
a week ago where she said it's time for
to hold these big tech companies
accountable
for disinformation and i'm like okay
but she's not talking about random
conspiracy
nutters she's talking about us she's
talking about anyone who challenges the
establishment narrative
because they might have their their you
know control of a bunch of different
areas of industry and they're destroying
it
but what happens when people are able to
listen to this conversation
well that's a problem because now people
are going to open their eyes and they're
going to be able to watch and
which brings me to the next story
they're being radicalized
here's the story from louder with
crowder youtube has suspended later with
crowder again
applies second hard strike on crowder's
channel
and a strike on their crowder bits
channel which is segments from the from
crowder's show
so that means though the one strike is
less relevant compared to the two
strikes
once you get two strikes you can't
upload or stream or post anything for
two weeks on
any channel you're supposed to be able
to but we know they already went after
crowder with a warning for trying to
explain that he got a strike
can't do that one more strike in crowder
is permanently banned
what's the hard strike mean it means
like
they could take your content down and
say we've removed your content but not
issued a strike for these reasons
but which they should do they should do
because
this this shows what they're doing to
crowder that their main goal is
literally just to get crowder banned
and justified in the press they're
claiming that by by crowder supporting
law enforcement action they were
cheering on death or tragedy and it's
like wait hold on
if the cops are doing what cops are
legally supposed to do
and you cheer for that isn't what we're
supposed to do or are we supposed to
cheer for lawless activity it's a
passive problem
i don't know the details on what he said
or how he said it but i do know that
they have had a target on him and anyone
else and you know they're going to pick
them off one one at a time i guess
so crowder pulled up a bunch of examples
of targeted harassment on youtube that's
fine
the covington kids was a huge example of
tons of people who got away with it
and they're clearly just going after
crowder the cliffs are going to erode
look i don't know maybe maybe the
crowder people don't want to hear it
when i say it but i think they are
gearing
up to nuke crowd what happens is as an
admin i was an admin at mines for like
five
six years or something so from my
perspective as an admin you when you
start to see users that you start to
resent
because they do so much stuff that makes
you make decisions about
is this a violation or is it not and you
have to like constantly be thinking
about it and stressing about it and then
you start to resent the person
and that's what's happening these people
there are admins that resent him
and are looking for reasons to destroy
maybe but they're also
heavily targeted by media matters you
google search stephen crowder and it's
all basically media matters articles
and i think a lot of it what it is is
there
i don't think it's personal necessarily
i think that there's people at google
who are just like
we are getting slammed by media matters
so just err on the side of it's a strike
don't give them the benefit of the doubt
what should happen they were talking
about mikaya bryant when a knife was at
the stab woman and they said sorry it's
justified that's the cookie crumbles or
whatever
and they said that was glorifying death
or something what should have happened
is they should have sent a message
saying we take another video with no
strike
to inform you that this is not
acceptable for future reference
that's it that's considered like a soft
a soft strike is when they take the
time i mean people would just call it
yeah like a strike from the channel
or like a removal or whatever and i
don't think they should have either way
i'm just saying if they were actually
concerned about crowder's
like demeanor or attitude they would
have taken it down and said we're not
giving you a strike but you can't do
that all right
a hard strike is basically like it's
supposed to be when like a
a person gets naked on camera well
actually i think you do that you get a
permanently band you get permanently
banned
if you like just like go crazy but there
are some channels that have exemptions
for for showing nudity and stuff if it's
science related
but like strikes are supposed to be you
spout a bunch of racist stuff and you're
angry and young at the camera and they
go yo
boom gone strike you can't do that don't
do it again crowder was like
an officer came here's what they did
well that's the law that's what happens
and
youtube was like strike yeah based on
they get
well i don't want to set myself up for
anything but i can't believe that i
have no issues uh in comparison to an
issue like that that makes it very clear
getting strikes yeah i mean uh yeah i
mean
i'm backing out of this conversation not
to draw any attention to my content in
particular but it does seem to me that
that is an overreach
and it's a it's part of their overall
plan which is how do we get rid of
crowder it's not like it's not like
enforcing their rules to the letter of
their rules same thing with alex jones
yeah
it was very obvious when they're going
after jones especially with sandy hook
stuff i'm like dude i get it the guy
said dumb things but that was like eight
years ago
and there and they keep bringing it up
and i'm like it's the weirdest thing
that's what they what they bring up
every time and it was interesting to see
it was coordinated with every major
network taking him out at the same time
they didn't like him for his political
message does he say
you know outrageous things oh definitely
yeah we got we got we got to com we got
content removed on
on this show because of things he said
because they don't like him even though
they're like no it's fun you can have
them on the show and then
there are certain people that they will
just try and get rid of and they will
not give the benefit of that out to so
the problem is
technically we all work for youtube
because they're the boss
they could fire you whenever they want
which is why we set up timcast.com
so that way they can't fire us they can
kick us off the platform now but not
terminate
our positions so the truth is though
if crowder gets nuked people aren't
going to leave youtube
they're not going to do it joe rogan
left youtube for spotify
and this in my opinion was smart um
first of all
you know he got paid out good for him
but it also means that
he's actually safer in a lot of ways i
know there was this attempt on spotify
by employees to get them banned and then
there were some episodes that got
removed
but it's a contract where spotify knows
what they bought into
and so joe is allowed to say things he
can't say on youtube
tons of things he starts to be careful
because media matters goes after him and
we know that companies are are suckling
the teeth of media matters desperately
terrified of them because they're
pathetic spineless losers
media matters or the companies media
matters the companies are they're both
um but but rogan still has it's it's
different he can't be banned outright he
can get criticized he can have to
apologize but not going to strike his
content remove him
or things like that so the problem is
people didn't go follow him
a lot of people did but a lot of people
didn't and a lot of people i've have
said like oh you know i'll watch his
clips i don't watch the main show
anymore
i haven't watched or listened to a
single joe rogan episode since he went
to spotify i've listened to one
me too i just got it one last week bill
was like you got to get the new one with
the
the uh the military guy that was talking
about aliens ufos
legit dude i'll find listen i looked
into
uh we turned it on it was it was it was
good it was it was classic joe rogan but
it's it's not easy you know like i go on
youtube
you know for for more than just podcast
vodcast videos whatever
and joe's on spotify and it's not an app
i use so it's just like out of sight out
of mind
it's free um and the stock of spotify
shot up like after they paid rogan his
millions however many it was hundreds of
millions or hundred million um yeah
their stock went up like billions and
billions of dollars the value of the
company
what a move sounds like joe got
underpaid then
but you know i mean 100 million dollars
and he's free i know but at the market
says very specifically that this 100
million dollar acquisition translates to
whatever how many billions of dollars of
market cap
equity this is why i think you know i'm
a very different person from joe for
instance
i would have just started a podcast
network i would have created an app i
would have created the podcast show app
and i would have announced
we're going to be signing podcasts to
this network and it would just take over
dominate and then that's it and you know
you know what i would do
i would tell the big networks you can
plug in to our feed
you know and it's going to like you know
work out some deal some cash deal
and then people i'll tell you this if
joe said he was going to launch his own
podcast app
and then he went to a bunch of top
podcasters and says how would you like
to be the first 10
podcasts on my app they'd be like sign
me up bro
what do i got to do because people would
go
to his app it might not be the same as
he's definitely going to get more
viewers than spotify said i don't think
spotify gave him audience he gave
spotify audience
and then imagine you look at some of
these other bigger podcasts now their
name gets to appear right next to joe
that would have kicked it off and then
joe could have done a deal with the
other network saying okay you want to
send a hit our content now you got to
pay us a a royalty fee
but he's already a wildly famous and
wealthy guy
who's always want to do and or you could
just take a hard million dollars and
keep talking to your buddies in your
basement exactly
not too bad i think it worked out for
him i think he's stoked he's like takes
a lot of the heat off his stuff is
amazing
he gets to hang out and talk about
things with less less like i understand
um look i don't know if joe wants to be
the biggest
fish in the sea and that was a goal but
i understand the the mentality of being
like i'd like to have less viewership
because this is too much
because you you you're a big target
everyone's coming after you the bigger
you are the harder you fall
joe got 100 million dollars he can hang
out with his friends talk about what he
wants to for the most part
and he's probably a lot is great i can
hang out with my friends and have
conversations and i
don't got to worry as much and he
doesn't have an isp either breathing
down his neck anymore because he just
uploads his video to spotify and it's
all that's great
yeah pros and cons i think a lot of
people were upset because he was he was
a
uh he is a very powerful figure in the
culture war but his position has
diminished since
leaving you know itunes and youtube and
all that stuff to work for some silly
swedish company
google is inside alphabet isn't spotify
they own spotify i'm pretty sure yeah
alphabet really is it google or
yeah can you google it oh my god could
you google it oh my god that's great
google should not be a verb
verify i'm pretty sure yeah it's owned
by alphabet
so it's just from one company to the
next it is right
i'm about to work it out it is daniel
eck co-founder
yeah who owns it which company alphabet
i think it's alphabet did you look it up
sure
uh i'm pretty sure that's so disturbing
did you look it up no i'm looking for it
did you just search is taking a long
time yeah it does take a long time
said daniel yeah did he sell it anywho
joe rogan's on spotify i'm not watching
i'm on spotify i acquired spotify in
april of 2017. there you go 41 billion
that's right 41. google did not buy
no they did i don't know man where's the
who owned spotify right now daniel eck
no it looks like they're not owned they
acquired it in 2019
google slash why is this so hard to find
43.4
four of us live on the air trying to do
one google search
shut up you dumb robot freaking computer
digital music news google alphabet
acquiring spotify and forty three point
four billion dollar cash
but it says acquiring did they actually
acquire it i think i don't know
is only worth four and a half billion so
we're merging three worlds
a lot of people mentioned that when when
uh joe switched over
that it was it's like still a google
property so what's the difference oh
right yeah he got paid a bunch of money
and he could do his thing so
look look look look what's gonna happen
now joe left
end of last you know mid at last year at
some point crowder is on the verge of
getting the axe we're
we here at teamcast.irl are probably not
long for this world year or two
so it's like we got to build up
timecast.com and that's why i want to
make it a network we're going to
we're you know we got a ton of work
being done the website in the back end
we're we're doing staging sites making
sure it's done right and we don't
disrupt everything once we get the new
site up it'll be amazing we're gonna
have a newsroom we're gonna have
articles being put up
uh already i'm looking to commission
minidocs
so you guys just gotta send us the many
dock ideas and port your portfolio show
us
show me some videos you've made we're
going to just be like here's your budget
go to wherever and film do what you can
and then we'll we're going to publish
this stuff we're going to start making
as much as we can
because uh we got to do it with if
crowder goes
joe's already off youtube so he's you
know it's less likely to be seen
and they've been banning people like
crazy they're pushing everything towards
the cnn
world view gotta gotta push back and
stand up i mean crowder's got his
website as well he's got lot of crowder
he's got mug club
so we gotta just build as much as we can
before we're all gone
i saw the tim pool network was like the
second most viewed right wing
youtuber next to crowder where oh some
something on twitter i'd say right
winger yes only by like two million
views or something
this is funny because there was a the
guy who did this i asked him like what
makes my channel right wing
and he's like well you're criticizing
democrats all the time and i was like so
is jimmy dore but you put him as
left-wing he's like well jimmy's very
different i'm like
when i was i i pulled up jimmy jimmy
dore his youtube and i pulled up mine
and we covered the exact same things in
the exact same way
and i was like so what makes mine right
wing in his left and it's like i guess
jimmy is like like more profoundly
like more directly left you know like he
says
and i'm like i'm sorry
it's because of your guests tim no no
this is this is not guess it's my main
channel
yeah oh so it's is it the red letters
it's kind of
maybe that's an inside joke from
pre-show no no no
no no no it's the the view of it people
look at it like well it looks
republican it looks conservative or
something and i'm like is that it
because i look at these lefties who hate
the democrats and all they do is reckon
democrats all day
yeah that's it that's why it's funny too
and the presses are like tim pool's
right wing and i'm like why because you
like the democrats
it's the red letters you tricked them
all well the red letter is just a
regular psychology thing red catches
your attention i figured out google
tried to buy spotify the talks didn't
the talks broke down
and now spotify is owned mainly by the
ceo and another guy so it's owned by the
all right so it didn't happen them
swedish boys they got rogan instead
basically
worth more than 43 billion in their
opinion and they get to hold on to the
company
wow geez and it is because that network
is man that's big
i i fear that uh knocking the grill over
i did sorry that a lot of people are
gonna cash out the moment they can
of spotify no no no just of of the
culture war
like i don't think joe ever signed up to
be a prominent figure in the culture war
he's just he was talking about the moon
landing or something in gorillas
i don't know bigfoot yeah and then all
of a sudden he starts talking having
interesting conversations
and then he starts you know getting in
the culture war because the culture war
is dominating and then all of a sudden
he's forced into this fray
he's probably like dude i'm out i don't
want to be here i'm a comedian
you know for us like we're more
political cultural politics
hard politics it's a very different
space and uh
i bet there's a lot of people who are
saying look there's i'm not gonna name
names
but there are some people who have been
posting about this recently that they
used to make political content and then
were like
dude i never was into politics i don't
want to do this and they've bailed out
they're doing
non-political things they're like i want
to get away from this going to video
games going to
skateboarding whatever because it's
exhausting it's terrifying
it's uh alienating it is awful politics
is terrible it's stressful it's full of
anger and hypocrisy
and it makes you a target makes you a
target it puts you at risk it doesn't
for most people it doesn't pay very well
dan tone
uh french revolution one of the guys
there was like robespierre and danton
were like buddies that kind of started
the french revolution danton was
quoted as saying before he was murdered
uh executed by his own people
that uh it better to be a poor farmer
than the medal in the politics of man
for sure and i thought about that what
is it i mean being a poor farmer
that sounds like a rich life to me as
long as you can eat and you've got the
fields and you got your land until
safety until one day they show up and
they say you there give me your chicken
oh
and you're like i guess and you hand it
over why does the tax man have to be
french
wait he said french she was down oh hey
don't blame me sorry sorry he was
talking about the french revolution
it's just the messenger wait what i
think you're right i think getting out
of the political
sphere because if we're entertainers
then
if we talk about politics people really
care especially if you know what you're
talking about
we were talking about doing bikini
newshour before the show yes here's
here's the goal you make a video where
the first minute is a review of one of
these like instagram women
and then you talk about israel palestine
so it's like the thumbnail is always
like a woman in a bikini
and then they click it and then you're
like this is a beautiful bikini here
this woman
so instagram no one can steal this now
here's the name you ready
thoughts and thoughts thoughts and
thoughts thoughts and thoughts thoughts
and thoughts
thoughts and thoughts so what you do is
the first minute you're like look at
this beautiful
this is our instagram account she has as
many followers she posts amazing photos
now israel has been retaliating you know
and just
perfect your your watch retention time
will be 10 like we'll be like 10 percent
right people are there for a minute but
you get a lot of clicks a lot of clicks
entertaining and then here's the news
it's a news program where we have three
segments
we've got bikini review then uh
80 percent of hard news in politics and
then
um shouting out my patreon exactly
right hit subscribe what jack what's
your favorite topic to talk about
my favorite topic to talk about in
general yeah oh geez usually
dad stuff fatherhood kids masculinity
being there for your family building a
good family
that's awesome yeah that's my number one
favorite thing to talk about number one
favorite thing to do scoring
pardon me scoring scoring yeah you know
like beeps and butthead
all they want to do is score score score
so they call it
i remember oh oh oh you mean like oh i
said yes beavis and butthead
that was definitely in my wheelhouse
when i was in high school that was like
the big shower
score was that was that the slang term
back then i guess right for like hooking
up
yeah yeah i mean you scored yeah but it
was for anything it was like oh i got
some skittles score
like yeah it's just anything win earning
points yeah putting points on the board
yeah but you know family stuff like that
i love talking about that i go to the
bathroom you guys wow
this is wrong letting us know we were
waiting for like some profound statement
right i was like okay what's the
what do you like talking about ian sir
all right wonderful
no man it's been it's been a pessimistic
past couple of weeks and like
the other day i was looking at what
stories to talk about
and then i realized all of these crises
were happening at the same time and i'm
like biden's just screwed up that's the
story the
meta story well so talking about
politics for me we
you know we talk about these other
channels that want to don't want to do
because i never did i didn't get into
politics on accident
i was in politics literally my entire
life i was doing i was writing songs
it was activism it was it was punk rock
and then i worked for non-profits
and then i went down and started you
went to these protests then i went to
occupy
i've been here the whole time it's funny
when people are like dude pool's a
grifter it's like
i've been talking about this for 20
years right i got nothing else that's
all i do
i still don't understand this term
grifter it's like you provide a service
that people want and most of it is
absolutely stone-free well so the idea
is
that you're going to say things you
don't actually believe
to get clicks i see which is hilarious
because your audience was red-pilled way
before you were and they all would have
been pretty pleased if you would have
that's entirely true
the people who comment are the red pill
people who are commenting because
they're red pilled
okay yeah yeah and i still think you
like if you watch crowder and you watch
me you can clearly see we have a
difference of opinion and how we handle
stories and our opinions on the stories
and our political policies
but uh this idea is that
i all of a sudden decided to support
trump because it would make me money or
something it's like oh yeah i chose to
be the weirdo odd person out when the
establishment is completely dominated by
democrats to make money
what do you what are they right to put
it's hard to put a target on your back
to people
people are leaving yeah people are
ditching the space they don't want to be
in it
and it's really funny to watch these
these former anti-sjw people
now just like basically these trump
supporters so dumb
i mean i'm not pro biden but like you
know but it's better than trump i'm like
shut your mouth you coward
you got names i'm not going to name any
of these people i can't but i can't
think of anybody that i
was familiar with who made a big a big
180 like that
oh tons of people they start pulling up
media matters articles they start
pulling up grifter content
so when i say grifter content there are
people who literally just sit around
pulling clips from this show
out of context oh yeah and my favorite
is like
so i explained i've tried explaining to
people how i've bugs money them
you know bugs bunnying is when you like
no i don't i have no idea i was just
gonna try to bs it so
it's when someone says we need higher
taxes and then you go we need lower
taxes and they go higher taxes
and then instead of saying lower taxes
you go higher taxes and then they go
lower taxes and you go i guess lower
taxes
it's like when bugs bunny and donald
duck yeah i'm sorry daffy duck donald's
a disney guy
we're we're hunting sea we've got rabbit
season duck season so i explained like
on this show like 10 times what it means
to bugs bunny someone
and then the the the reason i i i will
say this
you'll get the grifters who will pull
things out of context and then when
someone says tim you once said x i go
now i know you're not a viewer and i
shouldn't engage with you because i'm
like
the only way you would think that is if
someone fell for the bait and pulled
something out of context oh right yeah
yeah yeah so and then there are a bunch
of funny people where i said something
like abolish the police
and then remember when i was talking
about how i was just going wild with
twitter and posting whatever
yeah so then when i say abolish the
police they're like you don't actually
care about abolishing the police
you're just saying that because you're
gonna rile people up and i was like are
you arguing against me now when i say
abolish the police
i've actually created a situation where
the left is hostile towards the
idea that i would abolish police because
they come for me instead of what i'm
saying
then when i say something like tax the
rich they say you're a grifter
blah and then i'm like now think about
this for a second they're not
confronting the argument they never do
they go for the person you're a grifter
you're a liar you're a scumbag pim tool
so now i have a tweet that says abolish
abolish the police
and the leftists say you're a [ __ ] f
you tim pool and i'm like oh no
now all of a sudden all these leftists
are attacking me because i said abolish
the police
to an outside observer they'll see that
tweet and think the leftists are
right-wing
you see you see the point yeah they're
not act these people don't engage with
arguments
so they walk into these these traps
grifters will pull
things out of context they'll put up a
minute and then cut out the next minute
where i'm like now actually the point
there was that they'll bait this
and they totally miss the point they
call those um ad hominem attacks when
they go after your your person
if you make a point and then they attack
you as a person that's just twitter
that's part of
they call it fallacious arguments so be
aware of those
if you see those ad hominem is usually
it means to the man it's usually when
someone will say i think we need higher
taxes and you say but sir i believe we
need lower taxes
instead of arguing they'll say well
that's because you're a nazi yeah that's
an ad hominem
but what happens is if i tweet something
like vanilla ice cream is better than
chocolate
the leftists will just say you're a
[ __ ] f you go screw yourself
so now if i tweet something that's pro
left they'll say the same thing wow
in opposition to their own controlled
controlling opposition no the point was
that
i it's bugs bunnying people the p
because it's to prove a point a couple
things one
it shows they don't actually have
principles or ideology as i've long said
the woke left has no ideology it's all
about tribe so if you
as the enemy of their tribe say
something they must disagree with you
now i can say things like tax the rates
abolish the police
and you know joe biden's tax policies
don't go far enough and they get angry
and say f you you're stupid this is
wrong
because they hate me as an enemy of
their tribe get it i used to think that
people need a villain
to to like rally around and if they have
a villain then then they'll unify
so i tried to become the villain and it
kind of worked but it didn't really
matter the villain yeah i tried to be
the villain so that people can't be
an idiot you have but then at least
they're rallying and unifying for
something but i think it's not
it's manipulating people and it's i'm
almost to the point where it's you know
i felt this way
every so often like we've been sitting
here talking about this stuff for some
time
have things gotten better um
sometimes like what what things what
things what things uh
peace in the world situation no uh
inflation no
energy so at what point do we just say
i'm gonna take a bunch of money i'm
gonna put it in a liquidity pool through
unit swap or something to get a massive
return and just dip out
i believe we were all plotting that
right before the show as a matter of
fact
so so basically frozen aren't familiar
simplify it it's a crypto atm and
you can put money into it and if you
have enough to invest you get a massive
return because you're operating in an
atm
all right why bother working buy
property rent it out
to help people that's my mission but
nothing's getting better
well it's getting worse you don't always
see it on the surface the surface
tensions are boiling but
like the systems like mines and like
decentralized networking is advancing
who was the dude who was pushing the
rock was that sisyphus or sisyphus
yes yeah so imagine this guy's got to
push the rock up the hill for eternity
yep but at least the rock's going up not
prometheus
no no these guys stole from atheism yes
we're we're like sisyphus but the rock's
slowly pushing us down and we can't lift
it and we're like
so you're like atlas but you're actually
fatiguing it's done it's crushing you
i wouldn't you know i i'm not saying i'm
fatigued by any of this i'm just
questioning
are we doing something wrong well is
there a light
at the end of the tunnel yes
everything's just getting worse
it's got people are getting banned
people are getting removed it's like
wind resistance the faster you go the
more resistance you're going to
experience until you hit terminal
velocity and you can't go any faster you
can keep hitting the gas and burn more
and more and more but you cannot go
faster because of the resistance well no
you can
just burst into flames yeah you'll
explode or whatever but but there's a
terminal velocity where you cannot
because of the resistance and that's
also with communication
and you can talk to about certain things
so much until
the return gives you you know nominal
return
i i kind of feel like uh in the end
you just wait until cnn collapses under
the under the weight of its own
lack of credibility and then there's
going to be a massive boom
in you know spaces like this so long as
youtube doesn't shut them all down
or they get banned and so it feels like
an inevitability it's like you know
we're just one grain of sand in this
massive heap this this
you know sand avalanche or whatever and
right and the way that our system is set
up now it's so complex
that you have this criticality
right these little sand pieces fall they
sand they fall and once there's a
critical mass all of a sudden the whole
thing's you just think it's one little
sand one little thing
one little thing and then all of a
sudden you have a massive movement
same way exactly that avalanches
occur based on power numbers and uh
self-organized criticality it can
explain avalanches
using complex system science uh forest
fires i think
are similar in that regard i think
lightning works like that the runaway
breakdown theory
uh i'm not familiar with a few electrons
go and then a bunch of other ones fall
actually one electron goes and then
another and then they just follow
yeah well that's interesting but it does
happen and it the hourglass
is usually the very good example uh
where you just see the little grains
pile up and then all of a sudden
they just they all just kind of flush
down the side
it looks very stable looks like you're
just adding one grain at a time and then
also the whole system well done if
anything i learned from last year is
that what we're projecting
is likely to occur i mean we're being
logical about it we're pretty accurate
centralizing power in one social network
seems
seems like it's faulty seems like
there's a lot of possible failure points
so i would imagine that at some point it
will fail i don't know for sure
but we should live as if it will i think
it's kind of what we're doing with
timcast.com creating
networks and i don't just post on
youtube the posts go up on
bitshootandminds.com.com
they're mirrored when i post one place
it goes to all the places yeah
so that's like if i guess we get banned
from youtube we just start posting
directly some of these other platforms
and then have timcast.com as the central
hub
but the truth is man people stay on
youtube because youtube is the one app
where everything is
yeah but then it means your opinions are
filtered through that machine
and well what's been great is i've been
able through this audience that i've
been introduced here too to get a lot of
guys to sign up for the liminal order
and then there's where we do all of our
premium content and i don't mean just
like having talks i mean like
workshops coaching classes seminars
academies you know actual real life
instruction real world events we just
had 60 guys
meet up for a jamboree in illinois
farmland lots of gun
range time lots of barbecuing sports
feats of strength
it was a lot of fun what can you explain
liminal order a little liminal order
yeah it's my organization it's all men's
organizations based on values of
masculinity brotherhood and sovereignty
we are in tune with all these issues
that we've been talking about here tim
all the censorship
all the political oppression the tyranny
that's coming
and we decided hey this is our answer to
this kind of crap we're just going to
disconnect from these networks we're
going to create our own network
and we're going to work together to
serve each other to build a stronger
network so we can all get better
and it's been incredibly powerful and
effective we've got almost 600 members
now
and we just had like 60 of them for a
weekend in illinois of doing a bunch of
guy
guy stuff barbecuing 120 120 pounds of
meat
just for dinner uh we had a whole armory
out at the gun range there we did feats
of strength we had campfires and sports
events and it was
it was a blast did you go i definitely
went it was epic that's why i got a
little sunburn here
my nose is all peeling that's why you're
using the shea butter i was using this
shea butter so that's the limit order
and that's that's our
same idea is to get off of these
networks that you want to be
off the grids you want off of and on the
grids you want to be on
and that's the future for us i got good
news that's a liminal order we just got
the parking lot resealed i saw that
driving up today i was like man it looks
and smells like beautiful fresh ass it
smells
awful it smells like progress we're also
having the crew come in to
finish tearing down some of the old
insulation and ceiling stuff which means
we're really close to having the garage
venue cleaned out and properly set up
and then we're actually gonna do
probably like weekly hangouts so it'll
probably be like every friday night will
be a
small thing for certain members uh
it'll be probably really hard to get to
get tickets to become a lianas because
what we're doing is that if you give at
least if you're a member at least 25
bucks or higher
then you're gonna see the post before
the standard ten dollar members and so
we're doing that for a few reasons
for one you're you're getting access to
something specifically which is we'll
put up the post saying tickets are
available there's 20 available to come
for the friday night you know hangout
session
but it's also like the 10 bucks is just
to watch content you don't want to come
here you want to show up
and it also helps us filter out any
potential threats it's like a vetting
process
you got to be a legitimate member and
we're not going to tell you when the
post will go up so it's harder for
extreme weirdos far left to figure out
when and where
almost like we should send out an email
to members so it doesn't go public
there's not like a public it's not going
to be published it's going to be posted
to the site for only people who give 25
or more
and then it's going to be a random point
throughout the week and then it's going
to be first come first serve which means
it'll be really difficult probably for a
lot of people to
get the limited sellouts every night and
the tickets are going to be relatively
cheap but
for for the most part the selling of the
tickets is just another way to try and
screen out
yeah potential threats or whatever but
look there's like auntie for weirdos who
would pay a thousand bucks to get here
and do something crazy
totally looks like i need to raise my
membership tier up to the 25
jack you're here right now oh i'm here
right now i'm here
did you play music yeah you could just
show up i didn't even have to pay did
you play drums
i was a percussionist dude we got a jam
kit outside i'm not i'm not a trap
setter uh percussionist like orchestral
percussion
it's rock and roll it's not as cool as
being in a rock and roll drum center
though is it
what well let's take some what was that
can you adjust
tim's camera oh this one right here
no no don't go from the camera grab from
the the gold part yeah yeah thank you
lydia how dare you kick my camera tell
me when to stop that's good
there you go perfect jack was trying to
make sure that there were two characters
what's it doing why is it doing that
interesting it's being pulled by a chord
jack's trying to make sure ian gets uh
two cameras keep please put
his camera on tell me when to stop no no
you just stop but it's a rotating back
side you let go
yeah look at that man it's the it's the
power cable probably
you don't get this oh yeah the power
cable fell off i'm not kicking
it people are going to be able to see
things they're not supposed to be able
to see on youtube i'll hold it i hold it
all right jacksonville ian's coming
we'll take super chats while ian
tries to figure out why it's like oh we
got that's the power cable
the power cable is causing it to let it
go but no
there you go just boom everyone enjoy
how are we doing are we on tim's pretty
face you are all right there are some
things to my right i can't mention
that you could almost oh yes youtube
doesn't allow us to
show the table that is super shiny over
there it is
super duper shiny i thought it fit in my
hand
it was beautiful looks expensive custom
powerful
illegal illegal where i live that's too
bad but not here
anyway super chat smash the like button
you guys are rocking join timkis i can't
become a member
share this show smash take that link and
then you know post it wherever
anything you do we need to get a
professional like uh chat room
hyperperson to be like share the link
oh yeah all right let's read some super
chats we got gc
geek army who says there is no gas
shortage all the lines can be opened
manually they just don't want to
kind of weird this is mostly affecting
red states i think so too and i pointed
this out
today and the day before a bunch of
stories from two weeks ago where they
were saying there was going to be a gas
shortage cnn fox the guardian were like
expect gas shortages this summer i don't
know why someone would do it on purpose
if you're a retail
outlet you sell product there's no
reason to hold back product not to sell
it i went to gas stations in dc they
were out of regular fuel period unless
you're in a cult
oh right and there's some people who are
like we want to ban gasoline and whitmer
is like we're going to shut down this
oil pipeline during a crisis that's what
she did
i have to listen to her speak just to
see how good your impression she
probably talks like this don't you know
i don't know what she sounds like
otherwise i do a real impersonation ever
hilarious
steven 13 says you should check out the
movie greenland it is a realistic and
terrifying
take on the human reaction to a crisis
in the movie the earth is bombarded by
small comets eventually the big one
comes i watched it
felt it was fairly generic but i do like
that idea like so they're uh i'm going
to spoil it
spoiler alert for those 17 greenland
they're like in the house and only
select people get chosen the guys tv
says like jonathan
smith you have been chosen please
proceed to
and all the neighbors are watching like
uh where's my notification
we didn't get one only some people get
to
live i hope you got a big basement
it's the shattered comments that concern
me shattered
shattering of comments yeah oh this is
interesting
oh kyle buchanan says love y'all i'm an
hvac tech units will be going up twelve
percent june first
i'm investing in the best crypto bullets
that's right
wow and that's all at once they're just
deciding when they're gonna jack the
price i just bought a bunch of bullets
good feels like a good investment
because demand is going to skyrocket but
also inflation will make them harder
harder to buy
so i'm like buy them now cause i don't
know what else to buy other than food
you know but that's the joke people are
posting on twitter is
how many bolts do you need to get you
know someone's food and it's one that's
just one that's right
that's it but in actuality it's just a
gun because you could have nothing in it
people would still get scared and just
give you what you want you know
maybe batteries and solar panels
hopefully it never comes to that we
don't want to live that way
i want to be able to like just chill
with a rocking chair on the front porch
and be left alone i want to bring this
awesome technology to everyone on earth
nelson sepulveda says tim you are wrong
the government and the media said the
truth
there are no line for gas if there is no
gas there is no line
i tweeted that i was like can't have a
line for gas if there's no gas in the
station
right it's not a shortage it's there's
just not enough for everybody who wants
it right now
yeah that it's there's none that's not a
shortage it means there's none
see brad 81 says you need to have tom
mcdonald and
shoeonhead on your show if also like to
see you
on the drinkin bros podcast i have
spoken with tom mcdonald i believe on
uh more than one occasion he is he is
awesome his music is fantastic
but he has uh it's just really difficult
right now for a lot of people
and i think i can't remember i want to
put shoe on head on the spot but i don't
think she wanted to
i don't remember for sure though maybe
said she couldn't do it um because i
think
a lot of people can't travel right now
but trust me a lot of people are like
why don't you have these people
we asked everybody i like everybody who
follows me i've emailed
or dm'd and a lot of people are like nah
i don't want to do it i don't look tom
mcdonald and shoot don't need to come
on the show they have their own massive
platforms to speak their mind and do
what they want to do
yeah so it's like why would they fly out
here when they have
you know like shu has like a million
something subscribers he doesn't need to
come out here
tom mcdonald puts out a music video and
gets like tens of millions of views or
whatever he doesn't need to come and sit
here and talk to me
so that's the funny thing i see a lot of
people who have like these shows and
they're like you need to come on my show
and i'm like no they don't
yeah like they have their own show
that's why i i like the idea
you know joe brings out joe rogan brings
a lot of people who are just like
academics and researchers people who
don't have shows that make sense
yeah that's generally what i do i go
after authors and scholars and people
that don't have shows people that aren't
media personalities but are experts in
their field with really cool stories to
tell that's my goal
all right we got uh crandall logan says
tim you should buy a microwave cut the
cord
and put spare electronics inside a
microwave is a faraday cage to protect
against emps from world war
iii tim you keep criticizing the former
vice president the earth king invites
you to lake
laguai lao gai logai how do you
pronounce that
there is no war embossing say you know
that meme
uh i do not sir i am not i'm just i'm
not as internet as you dude
so in the show avatar there's a there's
a war going on between all these nations
i saw that and in the earth king the
earth city of bossing say
uh the government doesn't allow anyone
to talk about it so they keep people in
the dark
oh perfect and that's what's happening
now with like the shortages the
government's right there is no gas
shortage in southeast united states
there definitely isn't just not
everybody who wants it can get it
that's right it's different stop wanting
your gas and you'll be fine get in your
pot eat your bugs
john wifey says remember the last
economy crash due to the housing crisis
its catalyst was five dollar a gallon
gas making people decide on mortgage or
gas to work
oh man it says now our money is worth
less people are overspending and gas is
artificially being made scarce
i predict a spike in gas prices and
another collapse
i do not disagree let me introduce you
to a word
we haven't used for a while around here
called stagflation
stagflation that's where inflation goes
up and the economy goes down and
unemployment goes up
it is a bad place to be and the last
time we got out of uh stagflation it
took us
it took the uh first of all the federal
reserve your best friend
ian i can't believe i'm bringing it up
before you did
reserve federal reserve paul volcker
raised interest rates like 18
in 1981 which killed inflation and
kicked off a
40-year bull run in the market in the
bond market
which made an entire generation of fixed
income bankers
extremely rich maybe they're trying to
angle for something like that yet again
yep because the people who have hard
assets that retain their value
once the economy crashes can then buy up
a bunch of the assets for pennies on the
dollar and then swap back and there we
go
it pay look when they say it takes money
to make money that's what they're
talking about
all right kevin dobler says tim have
crowder on
yes crowder who gets tens of millions of
views and has millions of subscribers
i'd love to have him on but he has a
much bigger show so like why would he
stop or does he
nah i i he he's going to keep doing a
show on his website
but why would he be like i will not do
my show
and then go on my show i don't know you
know you guys got to make a deal where
you go on his show once
and he comes well but like he has he's
had been a show several times because he
does remotes oh we don't do remote here
i would like to have you on my show
because i would like to ask you my
questions at my
pace we don't do remotes we don't do
remotes i mean i might i might but i
might do a remote
for me yeah yeah yeah okay we'll talk
about it depends on how tired i am
uh-huh hardest working man in youtube
well sorry so a lot of people
i stopped doing the weekend stuff but
now we're back to working on weekends
again
so now there's no because we're now
we're doing the vlogs on the weekends
and so we're trying to ramp up into a
vlog every single day
and i only imagine that eventually my
head will explode yeah well you're young
mr bojangle says great work y'all from
active military i want to make sure to
correct something i heard back on the
6th of may from ian
i want to clarify the phrase wmd isn't
limited to nukes
saddam used gas attacks in his war with
iran and the kurds all respect
that is confirmed yeah gas
enrique lichtenstein says this one's for
ian look up the nasa video on lattice
confinement fusion
long-term future of energy is looking
very bright are you talking about the
palladium lattice where they bombard it
with
i don't know deuterium and uh perhaps
let's find out
amk says ohio governor mike dewine
announced a 1 million
lottery for those who have received at
least their first dose of the cova
vaccine per nbc news
why that is so weird
that just creeps me out tell me about it
i was i was looking up lattice
confinement ohio's doing a 1 million
lottery for people who get the vaccine
that's just so weird bribery
no no i was like but why do they need to
do that obviously because not enough
people
according to them are getting the
vaccine i saw i saw the other day
a woman a phd public health person
saying
that she thinks that the best way to get
vaccines rolled out to more people is to
go
down to bars where people are consuming
alcohol
and utilize the fact that they are under
the influence of a mind-altering
substance
and susceptible to peer pressure and
in an environment where things are
already inhibitions are lowered
that they should go around and just be
jabbing all the drunk people at a bar
this was made with a straight face we
got to get them when they're drunk and
susceptible to peer pressure and their
inhibitions are lowered
then we can jab them up with our
magnified chip and plants that hold your
refrigerator magnet to your arm i feel
like their immune system
their immune systems will be compromised
at the bar youtube doesn't know when
you're joking nor do they care
i'm joking i don't know did i say
something wrong i mean you just don't
care if you joke i don't look what they
do look what they're doing to crowder oh
yeah the crowder was like i support the
police and their actions and they're
like okay ban him yeah
i don't think um if you're under the
influence of alcohol your immune system
is
compromised or at least you're not
allowed to consent to sex much less to
get a vaccine
when you're under the influence of
alcohol i would imagine
there's just creepy people who also
don't believe in consent anymore
yikes yeah all right we got this from
justin jackson it says so tim and gang
with a storm in the distance you take
cover with the storm that is
inflation what can us young adults do
that have no experience dealing with
economic crisis besides voting people
out of office
i don't know in the old days they would
say buy land and gold
and bury a big pot of money dollars in
your backyard no no
no opposite that's what they did in the
20s no no that's the opposite that's the
opportunity
no yes when you when there's inflation
and you need something your incentive is
to go out and to buy it as quickly as
you can that was the gold standard back
in the day bro
when it's deflation that's when you just
take your money and stick it underneath
the mattress because why buy this thing
today that's going to be cheaper
tomorrow yeah buy bitcoin now and
i i don't mean literally i'm saying i
will buy bitcoin now and then wait for
it to just
so for a young person i don't know how
old he is or you are but um like what do
you do if you don't have
a large asset like what do you do one
thing you can do is you have to get
involved in a business that has
changing prices and that you have to be
responsible for your wages through your
efforts
right if you work for a company and
inflation goes up they're not going to
raise your wages right away
and in fact in the 70s i believe we even
put a cap on prices
put a cap on wages we didn't cap on all
kinds of stuff which led to shortages
and all kinds of terrible things
but today if you can get into a business
in which you are the person
that is responsible for generating
income and that income is a price that
you can
set on a day-to-day basis you can
therefore react then to your input
prices
if you have a big set of inventory and a
huge amount of investment that's going
to make it harder
but as long as you can buy and sell
something that which you can change the
price of yourself
that is a way to cope with inflation all
right this one's good
raleigh a murray says trump should have
his supporters register as democrats and
he should run as a dem in 2024
four out of five other dems will split
the dem vote and the dnc will implode
that would be epic
yes trump run as a democrat he would win
the primary
all right the one free man says michael
malus said kovitt gave bad people a lot
of useful info
on just how far they could push the
general public that's right
creepy jerry rosen says hey tim was
listening to your podcast with max
keiser about btc and disagree with him
i own a coin called luna doge it's a d5
token built to be a store of value
it incurs taxes that get redistributed
to its holders lts
interesting yeah i don't like tokens
unless they have actual
function tokens on the uh on you know
their erc20 tokens they're not the same
as coins
someone just decides to blink a million
tokens into existence
and they basically run off ethereum
unless they're doing something like
minds where they actually can be used to
gain access to like to boost content to
gain views like actually use it for
purchasing ad space
that makes sense yeah otherwise you know
like a d5
actual coin a you know like a um
necessarily a fork off of bitcoin but
you know copy of bitcoin technology
i think are better like dogecoin i like
but the shibu shiba thing i think is a
token
which is like a centralized just snap
you snap into existence i don't like
that
i know doge is uh inflationary but still
dr doctor says last super chat for a
while i'll be in the field planting
soybeans in corn for the next two weeks
as always thank you guys for putting in
the hard work and being the voice of
reason in a time where reason seems to
have gone out the window
thank you for showing soy some love oh
and as an aside did you guys hear
did you guys hear boogie is now in jail
oh man
i mean he should be yeah he fired a gun
in the air he did more than that oh
so here's here's a quick story for the i
don't know i'm just it did someone
remind
i i thought of it right now so you're
you're gonna hear this jack i'm
listening tell me do you know about what
happened with this
two guy boogie29888.2988 nope big
youtuber right his uh
he was really really big at one point
he's still fairly big he was getting i
guess they were saying he was being
harassed by some guy
shows up to his house the story most
people tell
is that boogie is out goes outside and
has a gun and warns the guy you're
threatening my family get off my
property
you know or i'll i'll shoot you and the
guy tells him to fu and he's swearing at
him and saying slurs and then boogie
says i'm gonna fire a warning shot and
then fires the gun in the air
in a residential neighborhood so a lot
of people are like nah he shouldn't be
getting arrested or charged
that guy was harassing him let me tell
you guys what happened because you need
to watch the video
the dude was harassing him i mean or the
the dude was definitely
i should say trolling him online
harassment you know there's different
definitions of people so trolling him
and did show up to his house in the full
video
boogie is goading him back saying i'll
show you a [ __ ] bud i'll show you
and doesn't call the cops takes a gun
from someone else and says i'm coming
out there
all right protect my dog i'm going out
there opens the door to confront the guy
then points the gun in the air and says
i'm going to shoot it i'm going to shoot
it and shoots it
you can't do those things you can't do
that all right i'm sorry
someone comes to your house and is bang
on the door screaming swear words and
slurs you call the police
you take your weapon and you say do not
come into my house or i will use lethal
force and then you wait for the police
to arrive
you don't open your door to the
perceived threat stand in front of them
and say
i'm warning you i'll shoot because what
that proves to a court is
by opening the door you are not
threatened you did not feel a threat you
actually inv
you opened confrontation you invited
confrontation by pointing the gun and
then saying i will shoot you
and not actually taking a shot you are
proving you did not feel threatened
a person who feels threatened
immediately just fires
someone kicks your door in you don't say
hey hey don't come to my house
but even then you have a better argument
than going out and confronting somebody
so his court is on the 28th and i think
he is going to get the book
thrown at him and a half it's going to
be
i'll knock this guy out what is this
what is the charge for firing a weapon
aggravated assault it's a class d felony
in arkansas so it's uh
up to six years in prison and if you use
a firearm it's 15.
jesus if you use a firearm and
aggravated assault 15 years so this dude
could be potentially
so this dude who shot a gun up into the
air he didn't do that he went like this
okay but not at them he fired it like in
the direction of homes
and sure and those bullets come down
fast sure they do um
i'm just i can't because of 38 i'm not
i'm just i'm
like i think the last time i was here
was the night that those two girls
carjacked
uber each driver stole his car and
killed the men
anwar yeah they're getting off
well they're getting they're getting
sentences they're not even being tried
as adults they're going to be out
they're going to be done yeah but aren't
they going to go actually go to
to juvie yeah yeah they're going to go
to jubilee big deal yeah they're going
to go to juve a big deal but this guy
who had a guy at his house was harassing
him or whatever he walks outside he
shoots it over their head he's going to
go prison for 15 years
that bullet comes down somewhere but did
it yes
on whom he probably hit someone's house
i don't know that's why he's not getting
a murder charge yeah he's getting an
aggravated assault charge
15. he's not even getting an attempted
murder charge that's up to
yeah some uh i i think it's it's
possible that he could get
a plea deal down for like a year
probation or something i mean people
murder people and get less than a 15
year sentence yeah that's the maximum
yeah aggravated assault with a firearm
in arkansas would be like in that
circumstance they're probably imagining
you walk up to someone and put the gun
in their face and scream at them yeah
yeah yeah
he was close to doing that listen if
someone comes to your house i understand
you're mad
but opening your door telling the guy
i'll show you who's a [ __ ] bud
that's what he said yeah that's like
dude you're not scared of that person
when you do that you're angry at that
person
when you open the door to them you are
not worried they were going to injure
you or your family
you actually were inviting the
confrontation by doing so and he only
called the cops because afterward the
other guy in the video was like oh you
should call the cops man he's like okay
i guess
yeah the police wouldn't even funny
thing is by calling the cops now he's
going to jail
if they didn't call the cops nothing
would happen so the guy went there to
get under his skin and her ass oh he was
saying crazy stuff
and man did he succeed that sucks do not
be drawn into their fight
dude the gun wasn't even his don't take
someone else's gun
open your door to someone you claim is
threatening you and fire a gun in the
air in a residential neighborhood that's
insane
and a lot of people are like they're
defending him and i'm like dude i get it
he was being you know
he was upset he was being trolled by
this guy he's saying he was being
harassed by this guy
but good luck proving to a judge you
were actually scared of that person
you don't get to fire a gun at someone
you're mad at because they're harassing
you i'm sorry that's not how it works
yeah anyway i digress let's read some
more chats sonny james says i'm actually
excited about panic buying
despite all the decision division among
us citizens of the us
we all agree on one thing we don't trust
our government when they tell us not to
panic we all do
and we've been right so far creepy right
handyman tn says tim think quick what is
your single best advice for a new
youtuber start making videos
just do it and get better at it
every day make a video work as hard as
you can and just
get the ball right have a good
microphone that's a big part of it i
don't know just get started you can have
crappy lighting but if the audio is
really good that goes a long way now
when i first started i had a gopro a
gopro 4 with crappy audio
and then if your content is good quality
can improve afterwards did you share
your stuff
that's exactly how i started shoehorn
had used as a webcam
when i started i would right click all
the comments i'd go to another vlogger
like boheme he was a popular and i so i
right-clicked on all the commenters and
opened all their pages and then messaged
them each individually this is my new
video so i would take 12 hours a day or
10 hours a day
publicizing my stuff did you spend a lot
of time publicizing your work in the
early days
none i started off with a crappy mic and
a crappy webcam
started off doing just audio and now
content was good and then it took me
time and i finally i finally upgraded
all my equipment it's all pro level now
and man we're killing it yeah i had i
would take a gopro 4
and i'd put it on top of the monitor and
i just press play and then i'd record
like a 10 minute thing every day and
that was it
and then i just started you know getting
the flow of things once i streamlined
the process got a better camera upgrade
upgrade upgrade upgrade and just start
doing it you can't get good at something
unless you just start doing it don't
worry about
the biggest mistake people make is
trying to build a massive foundation yes
is this true for any startup yes they'll
lay this million dollar concrete
foundation figuratively or literally
and then find out they're in the wrong
place right so if you go out and buy a
bunch of expensive microphones and
cameras
and you don't know what you're doing
with them you've just wasted a bunch of
money when you find out
i actually don't need that i actually
need something else
so i have a black magic switcher on my
desk that's one of those things that i
don't need
as well listen this is this is something
that i talk about a lot inside the lo
which is
uh the ooda loop observe orient decide
and act
it's a great way of making decisions and
adjusting yourself to circumstances
we like to turn that around and do act
first
act then observe orient and decide
action
to orient take action to figure out
where you are just get
started you will learn more by screwing
up then you will ever learn by reading
books or being mentored or tutored or
taking a class
or anything get out there and make
mistakes mistakes are progress yeah
how long after you started did you start
to see a return
financial returns yeah i guess
financial's one way to look at it uh day
one
oh were you already in the partner
program i had a youtube channel already
i was working for
i just left disney and i made a gofundme
where i was like
uh i'm gonna go to sweden and then a
bunch of people started tweeting it out
we raised a bunch of money i went to
sweden we got millions of views
so a call to action so uh when i first
started
making content content was good i was
streaming at occupy wall street
and so within i think like two days i
was getting 2 000 concurrent views
per live stream if nothing was happening
i'd get about 700
because i went to occupy wall street and
people wanted to know what was happening
so i was interested in something
goings-on i went there and i filmed
stuff
and it was a product that people had a
demand for a high demand how do you get
access
inside this camp now there are other
people who are doing live streams with
laptops but they weren't talking
so you would turn it on and just see
someone pointing a camera at random
things
it's contextless no one understood i
started streaming and talking at the
same time and then also people were like
now i understand everything you'd see a
tent so that tent over there is where
the sanitation people are they have mops
in there it's like oh
now that guy over there he gives
everybody tamales every day oh
and then i immediately within like a
couple days 2 000 viewers
then it was like 20 050 and then i think
we had
i don't remember how many viewers we had
during the occupy raid but it was like
22 hours and it was like a combined 200
million views across
all syndication or something ridiculous
okay look here's one last piece of
advice tim just told you his story about
going to
occupy wall street i have similar
experience and going to the riots in dc
in may and june and july of last year
the moral of the story is go to where
the news is
if you're doing news if you're doing
news go to where the news is
or become the news those are two very
good ways to get a lot of people
yeah uncover like the inner workings of
an industry like i was an actor in la
and so people wanted to see what's it
like to be
an actor in la so i would like tell them
my daily experience i went to an
audition
i'd go to the theater and i would they
were very that seemed to interest people
too
all right let's read some more we got
connor o'brien it says tim judgment day
is coming
i formally refuse to partake in
anti-racism training at work
i'm anticipating getting canned for this
any need for a tax accountant project
manager in the business
uh yes actually you can send an email to
jobs at timecast.com but we are so
overloaded it's very difficult for us to
get to any of these emails i desperately
want to get pitches for minidocs but
again we are so overloaded it's very
difficult
to go through this i have no time with
that budgets are you looking to hand out
for those mini docs
uh entirely depends i suppose yeah not
big ones
um i'll just put it this way i can't say
exactly
but i can't say vice's budgets ranged
from 10 to 50k
yeah so i don't think we're in vice
territory yet no you're way bigger
what way more relevant just kidding
sure sure yeah but in terms of having
access to capital and not so much
so um but enough to make good stuff so
it just entirely depends
if somebody like wants to drive down to
georgia uh what we want to do is i want
to i want to
get some interviews with people there's
a town in georgia where gun ownership is
mandatory
have you heard of it no yeah someone was
talking about it the other day but i've
been
you know following the story yeah you're
you're required by like town charter to
own a gun
is it anywhere near atlanta because i'm
going to be in atlanta pretty soon i
don't know i'll have to look it up i had
an idea about
i'll check it out a ghost hunting show
i'll tell you about it off air i don't
want to blast one of the one of the
things i
want to do is a lot of people have
mentioned potential paranormal stuff
but anything we do with paranormal is
going to be academic so
you know we've gotten hit by people who
are like we want to do evp
and like seances and i'm like i don't
i'm not going to do that it's not going
to happen what i would like to do is
actually
have someone go to a haunted house a
known haunted location
and then someone else go to a new build
a building that was just built
and then a similar of similar structure
or similar composition
and then do a series of tests with a
variety of like
energy detection devices and then as a
control group and then test to see if
there's differences
it's not perfect because the ground
comes will be different we don't you
know there could be
mine underneath who knows i figured out
the secret but at least starting from
the basic scientific approach of we're
not going to do evp
garbage that's made up we're not going
to use emf detectors
you know in in the way they doing these
ghost hunter shows we will have them but
a lot of what they do is just made up
stupid stuff
i want an actual academic view of
haunted locations why are they haunted
why do people report these things are
they making it up can we do some
legitimate scientific research
and then be like here's what we found we
don't know what it means here's some
data
who's doing it some universities
probably i'd like to film it
100 i'll talk about it i don't want to
blast out everything
all right josh oliver says hi love the
show i actually sent you an email about
getting on as an intern
and also a project idea for creating
culture in the world of writing i don't
live far from y'all and would love to
chat
josh oliver um pitches at timkes.com but
again
we are so overloaded trying to get
everything done
we probably need to dedicate a good week
to hiring like five people
so that we can manage out all these
projects properly
first thing you should do is hire
somebody who hires people and then you
just don't have to worry about anymore
quality control man
but yeah like a yeah like a hr person
but they got to be like top tier best of
the best and it's not easy to do
yep you people are the hardest parts of
any business
managing personalities tyler102401 says
i was wondering two things would you be
willing to finance a business venture
it is a medication that promotes mental
longevity called batacath care
also where can i buy bitcoin um max was
mentioning swan bitcoin right oh yeah
yeah so we'll shout them out i've not
checked them out but uh that's what
max was saying and max is smart um so i
don't know
look into it and batacath care
interesting i would not be interested in
getting anywhere near that unfortunately
yeah i'm not confident in bad at cat
care what is it battlecath
jonathan howe says elon musk said tesla
will no longer accept btc
but is looking into other crypto doge is
the future let me explain
something we often see very powerful
individuals say
we are denouncing bitcoin and then the
bitcoin price collapses
and then lo and behold a bunch of
wealthy individuals buy up the bitcoin
at a discount i think jamie dimon did
that
was he the ceo of jp morgan or something
kept saying bitcoin no bitcoin no
and then when bitcoin prices tanks all
of a sudden he's like bitcoin yes
elon musk put out a message he said we
will no longer accept crypto because of
the environmental factors
a bunch of smart people then quickly
pointed out bitcoin uh
miners are using renewable energies
because it cuts the cost because they
have to pay for the energy in the first
place
so that's not correct elon says in the
message
so we will not be doing transactions in
bitcoin nor selling it
what did elon really say hold on for
dear life
right he said when they were doing
transactions and bitcoins
uh in bitcoin there's a possibility that
they would give some up because they're
doing a free exchange no they don't want
to do that bitcoin's gonna go to a
million bucks
so now that they've accepted a bunch of
bitcoin for cars they stop it
and now hold the bitcoin forever and
using environmentalism as an excuse
in my opinion i think they just want an
excuse to hold on a bitcoin and not give
it up you see they were selling bitcoin
too
so transacting in bitcoin means you know
uh back and forth i suppose and they
mentioned they will no longer be selling
it
hmm or yeah yeah
interesting you would think you would
think that a pretty decent size of their
market were people who had
you know crypto wealth and like hey let
me just buy a buy a tesla with my
crypto yeah dogecoin can you buy tesla
oh he just posted on twitter should we
accept doge for teslas
i didn't i think vampire slayer says tim
you perfectly described how philip
defranco used to run his channel with
thoughts on thoughts
he started with an internet model and
then talked news that's right
that's awesome and he had the same name
i came up with too thoughts and thoughts
is that what it was i don't know yeah
basically
thoughts on thoughts thoughts on
thoughts that's hilarious
great minds that's true uh one of casey
neistat's videos
it's um what's it called make it count
the thumbnail is like two women in
bikinis and taking a picture of it and
that stuff
legit works people click on that stuff
they want to see oh beautiful men they
click it
all right sonny james says i subscribe
to a lot of leftist channels that i love
i've yet to find one who at the same
time wants to abolish police and prisons
yet they are either gun control
advocates or stay silent who they think
are gonna seize the weapons can't have
it two ways
which is why it's funny and
all right let me just let me just point
something out you come to a show like
this
i think we're fairly logically
consistent in that regard
but you go to some of these lefty
channels and they're like abolish the
police and guns it's like
did you think for two seconds oh i'm
sorry many of these people think two
plus two equals five so i'm not
surprised they can't do standard math
don't say it what ian jack don't goad me
don't start on this don't go me into
this don't start you're on my property
i am just kidding ladies and gentlemen
if you haven't already smash
that like button we're going to do a
bonus segment over at timcast.com
so you must become a member i have good
news you can now sign up with stripe
because a lot of people said i need an
alternative to paypal and stripe is
amazing
10bs.com click that big beautiful
members only button then you'll see at
the top bar members area and that's
where you will find the segment at about
11 or so we put it up
and there's like a rendering thing or
whatever but we get it up just before
the end of the day and then you can see
this huge library of contents amazing
the website's going to be reformatted
soon we have a lot of really amazing
stuff and it's going to be
it's going to be awesome we haven't
we're putting together a newsroom
which means we're going to have regular
old articles we're going to have a
standard blog section and we're going to
have an
additional piece of bonus content that's
right because ian was talking with dave
smith about the fed
i finally got a chance to pick dave's
brain he's very very smart
that was a great conversation bill was
there too and that will be up at
timecast.com
excuse me so make sure you go and become
a member smash the like button subscribe
to this channel share with your friends
leave us a good review
you can follow the show facebook.comcast
irl we are leveraging facebook in the
attempt to grow our channel so help
share our videos
spread the word and we're also on
instagram at tim cast irl
thanks for hanging out because we are
live monday through friday at 8pm so
we'll be back tomorrow
and uh jack has a channel i do have a
channel jack murphy live on youtube new
videos every day at noon i've got jessie
kelly tomorrow
i got a couple of up-and-comers coming
on friday other huge guests
former cabinet member coming up on jack
murphy live
we got a lot of great guys coming up
check it out and if you're interested in
masculinity
brotherhood and sovereignty join the
liminal order that's liminal hyphen
order dot com come sign up for the
mailing list i heard you also have a
book
i have a book it's called democrat to
deplorable in fact uh tim had a mug of
mine around here at one point someone
stole it the
oh well we'll have to get you more it's
a great great mug great mug tim drank
out of it one day it was amazing
best picture i ever took uh yeah
democrats are deplorable that's
available on amazon as well
describes how we got to this point in
the culture war right you know you can
always follow my work at ian
crossland.net and follow me on social
media ian crossland i love you guys
thank you for coming
he's a tremendous follower i try and
post the most intelligent
thing and you are hey you
hey you but yeah yeah yeah i was gonna
say you're more than welcome to follow
me on twitter i am sour patch lit and
i'm trying to beat
sour patch kids and followers
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you